foreign
hey everybody what's going on it's
Monday that means it's time to talk
about a haunting among other things yeah
we saw this one last night I've seen it
several times but this is the one this
is one of the episodes where you watch
it but you don't remember much about it
because the way the story is told
it doesn't really tell you exactly the
details of what happened so a lot of the
case doesn't really stick out it's kind
of generalized but it is a good case
because it involves Poltergeist and it's
the kind of poltergeist that me and my
family saw up in Mammoth Mountain and at
Lois's house and um the investigator
describes a phenomenon very
very clearly what they don't describe is
what exactly happened during the
phenomenon all the time but we're going
to get into it
um
all right looks like people are still
Henry van Pierce said it's so cool
YouTube will notify me the exact minute
when you start streaming live so I can
plan my lunch around watching 13 o'clock
that's funny I do the same thing like
because I usually eat lunch in my office
you know like Tom will bring me food
which is really nice of him and uh I
always am like I can't eat until I found
something of sufficient time and
entertainment value to watch while I'm
eating I can't just like eat and like
not be looking at something yes [ __ ]
Thanksgiving man where am unplanning
Thanksgiving and uh Jenny's laughing
because she knows I'm gonna talk about
it
I know it's if you're not in the United
States like you know uh Thanksgiving is
coming up on Thursday which is yeah the
big feed I love Thanksgiving and I've
been cheating
myself I've been cheating because
turkey in certain locations has gone
down to 45 sometimes 49 to 45 cents I
think we got it the other day for 42
something 42 cents I think it was 42
cents a pound right that's phenomenal so
a lot of times they'll say limit one or
two per customer
but I keep going back yeah like
different days and we go back like
separate and yeah
that whole
storage freezer that I have downstairs
is filled with turkey
we have eight turkeys you guys yeah
eight or nine they're actually nine turn
I think there's nine there's nine turkey
we have nine turkeys am I getting there
they're not all like massive they're
like most of them are kind of like 10
pounds most of them the small ones yeah
but it's it's twice the size of a
chicken and you could do a lot with
those turkeys I'm not telling y'all to
cheat
but that's pure protein you know real
lean protein it's versatile
and uh right now
it's time to buy a turkey
and there's there's plenty of them
sitting there
you know they're not having a problem
supplying
at least at Publix which is where like
that's over just a mile up the road from
us they've had the [ __ ] ton of Cherokees
I can't even just getting rid of them
yeah so I keep coming going by and
looking if there's turkeys there I'm
saying yeah I'm gonna get turkey
they're only like five bucks a turkey
yeah for a bag like for a nine or ten
pound actually I think they might be
bigger than that that's a surprise
that's cheaper than a chicken I think a
chicken is six dollars yeah
and it's half that size
so I'm just giving y'all a heads up all
right and then after Thanksgiving the
day after the [ __ ] that didn't sell
they're gonna go on sale even more I
might get a couple more well yeah why do
you think everybody goes to get candy
like the day after Halloween because
everything is 50 and I tried selling
that [ __ ] off I'm gonna go back and see
if they got any Ultra cheap chicken
turkey turkeys because I got freezer
space in there man and so like I said I
love turkey I never get sick of turkey
and like I said you don't even have to
like roast you could like make soup out
of it just like I like turkey sandwiches
I like it better than chicken so you
know I can eat turkey all the time um
you can couple times a week you can cut
it into quarters and sections and um
uh to cut the leg Parts apart and uh
batter them and fry them like fried
chicken there's all kinds of stuff you
can do with them yeah exactly yeah you
can do most the same thing you could do
with chicken yeah do barbecue barbecue
sauce like I said you make turkey
tetrazzini yeah that's good you can make
anything you want anything you want yeah
they're frozen to keep for a long time
so yeah I think we bought a bunch last
year and I think like we like a year
later yeah we like less than a little
less than half about eight months like
eight months later we had another one
and it was yeah it's a taste of just as
precious yeah you couldn't tell yeah it
was awesome yeah but yeah like I think
after the show like Tom's gonna go down
and start chopping veggies yeah I gotta
put stuff in and whatnot impressive I
gotta prep up some vegetables to do some
and do some pumpkin like for the pies
yeah cook pumpkin I got special
pumpkin pie pumpkins
and then I'm gonna
um cut up Celery and onion to get ready
to make stuffing
I'll do that it won't take long really
it's just just something to do
get stuff done early so when turkey day
comes you're not really just loaded down
I'm gonna make um
a bunch of
bunch of um pumpkin pies
and a uh I got some Karo syrup I'll make
a compact because I got a bunch of
pecans too so I make a pecan pie that'll
be good yeah I like apple pie also but
we don't have the stuff for that pumpkin
pie can be frozen too once I get rid of
a pumpkin pie pecan pie it's easy Once
one once one of those turkeys is gone I
got a place I could stack UPS any extra
pies
so get it all done you know I'm very
excited I got a lot of Frozen I love to
eat so Thanksgiving is really one of my
favorite holidays I bought a whole bunch
of pumpkins from a local Farm here and I
cooked them and got the meat out of them
and froze a lot of it some of it isn't
Frozen just ready to go that's going to
be in the pies but that Frozen stuff
that'll be good for months in there well
we already used a little bit of it we
made some soup and we made like a Thai
curry to hide pumpkin and sweet potato
in here yeah that was good too that soup
was also delicious yeah I got sweet
potatoes I Grew From The Garden and make
maybe make a sweet potato pie out of it
because they're not really big enough to
eat
I pulled them a month early because it
got cold yeah it's trial and error yeah
in Florida it got cold well I mean cold
for Florida it got down into like it got
down to like 53 degrees Fahrenheit which
is called that's cold for Florida they
said two and a half months but really
they said if the weather gets cold it
should be three and a half months and
then they'll get bigger only some of
them were big
oh well yeah should they say you got to
give it an extra like I said they're
still usable I mean like just you don't
bake them like you know you can just mix
them in with other things you know yeah
make them into a puree yeah to make uh
sweet potato pie don't matter how big
they are yeah yeah and sweet potato pie
is the true
Southern
um
dessert not pumpkin
although I heard that the original was
sweet potato
I mean they tastes pretty similar to
that pumpkin pie might have been a copy
of [ __ ] sweet potato pie I don't know
hard to say I don't know but it's all
back in antiquity
and like I said they're both good so I'm
not really all that concerned about it
to be honest most people can't most
people can't tell them apart that's what
I mean it's well because once you get
all the cinnamon and Nutmeg and all that
kind of stuff in there too it like
tastes exactly the same so you know uh
Danny Rowling said you guys reviewed all
the good episodes it's slim pickings
anymore of a good episode yeah it is I
mean that's we got a lot of episodes
left there are a lot of episodes left
like even in the box set that we haven't
really covered and some of them like
might be good we just like forgot them
you know right
so it's that uh then he says John zappis
in his house in this episode made a [ __ ]
ton of appearances in other episodes
yeah I noticed that it's like not only
do they have the same actor playing
John's office in this but they also have
the same house playing John zappos's
house he probably did them all the same
time that's what I'm thinking because
this one you know because last week you
know we did the possessed and this one
has a lot of similarities with that like
it ends with an exorcism it's not quite
as
uh dramatic it's not kind of like over
as over the top and the weird thing
about this one is that well maybe I'll
get into this in a little bit but
there's like some really weird
editing choices like during one part of
it which I've never seen on the show
before since so I mean we'll get into
that it's just it's very very strange uh
I remember said uh LOL I just Googled
for some info on this haunting episode
the first result is the podcast
occurring right now The Internet Is So
Meta
I guess because I mean this episode is
old like I think it first aired in like
back in 2007. so it's not like anybody's
really like searching for this [ __ ] like
other than my idea we're Reviving this
[ __ ]
and I kind of wonder if this lady is
still around because the lady that's on
I think she was on her name is Stacy
Jones
and she's a Paranormal Investigator and
I think she was on a couple of other
episodes she might have been on hidden
Terror or something like that but she
was on a couple of other episodes and
she had a website for a while that was I
think it was called Stacy Jones ghost
cop or just ghostcob.com or something
like that but I think like when I went
to it it wasn't
um get functional anymore but there were
some articles about her that came out
like a few years after this one so I
don't know if she's like still around
but she did um for a while she kind of
like founded that big paranormal group
like in uh Central New York or whatever
that had like a whole bunch of
investigators like I read an article
like that came out in 2012 like five
years after this show and her thing that
her paranormal investigation team that
she founded she started out with like
three or four people and then it was
like 75 people like working there which
I was like holy [ __ ] really like where
do they get the money from
do they charge people like to come and
investigate their [ __ ] because I always
kind of thought that a lot of the groups
don't
or do they just have like people how
many was it 75 yeah no it's just it's
probably just volunteers an online group
there's probably probably somebody in a
dab it does sound a lot paranormal
impressive when yeah like yeah we're all
we're honorary members yeah back when
the internet wasn't that big they're
probably all once same [ __ ]
paranormal web group you know what I
mean they're all [ __ ] converged on
that [ __ ] I guess right remember the way
the old internet was back in the 90s
well it wasn't the 90s This was 2007. oh
2007 well 2007 and then the article
where they said it was 75 people was
2000 2007 still that was just ten years
ago 2007 still kind of had primitive
internet though
that's true it was still kind of
primitive
even YouTube really wasn't YouTube as
you know it that was the Wild West it
was good though the [ __ ] was slow
couldn't that couldn't upload an HD
there was no such thing as really HD
everything was like a 240 or [ __ ]
three something you know 350. I remember
that [ __ ] it's [ __ ] funny
Danny Rowling said that ghost haunting
show on Animal Planet had some pretty
good episodes especially the episode
about the haunted restaurant in eastern
Pennsylvania that was haunted by a
mobster I think I kind of remember that
one we didn't like watch that one as
much I think that one's just called The
Haunted kapook's face what's she doing
her head came up in this Creek
asking you for something what's going on
did you did you guys talk about haunted
animals yeah yeah pokies these demons or
ghosts or something she's always like
looking up at the ceiling look at the
ceiling fan like well sometimes even
when the ceiling fan isn't on she'll
jump up on my desk and like look up in
the corner and I'm just like are there
demons up there you can tell me she says
she won't tell me okay she won't tell me
so let's see who's uh showed up is
anybody saying anything
I'm talking about Animal Planet okay
yeah I think that show's just called The
Haunted right
I think it is called The Haunted yeah
which is confusing what is it like you
know why don't they call it something
animal adjacent Well because most of the
stories don't have any animals that we
talked about that that one's not a bad
one either it's just that everything the
way it's it's it's edited it's real
fast-paced and real special effects
heavy and real light on um
story or testimony they just kind of
although I haven't seen it in a long
time then they throw a dog in there
because they have to mention yeah the
dog went Earth
yeah a dog or a cat or barked at nothing
one day yeah the dog get barked we don't
know why okay that dog never barks okay
okay so obviously they contractually had
to mention animals so it did really seem
like that because sometimes it was
really like shoehorned in there yeah
because they're like yeah one time like
the kitty was walking down the hall and
like all her little hair went yeah you
know what I mean it was like that well
actually I read that they were contract
contractually obviously well that yeah
to mention an animal because they were
on Animal Planet yeah
an Animal Planet were probably like well
it's like we're conflicted because we
really really want a paranormal yeah but
we don't really have like any really big
cases that are completely revolving
around anyone's pets yeah so we're not
gonna have to they were scraping the
bottom of the barrel yeah when we got
there we did find some dead insects and
there's
that's an animal technically we don't
know what insects were dead they were
just up on the windowsill okay it is
still a good it is still a good show
Danny rolly said it is actually like a
lot of the hauntings and stuff are are
good it's just it's I always I'm always
amused by like how they're gonna like
shoehorn the kitty or the doggie in
there the best one from the early 2000s
or the 2008 2010 2007 I think period was
that Canadian one I think it was called
paranormal encounters or what was it uh
yeah what the [ __ ] was the name of that
I think it was yeah I like I liked that
guy that hosted it it had the Korean guy
up in the damn skyscraper up in Canada
[ __ ] introduced and he was kind of
like the uh kind of like the rod stew
better
we're gonna name him after some [ __ ] I
guess I've always called him that is
since I was a kid yeah I'm sure that's
not oh you're not the first person yeah
that mistake though yeah the uh but I
think it was called I think it was
called paranormal encounters something
that's kind of an issue I have though
and that's kind of like an extension off
what we always talk about like with the
haunting episodes having these kind of
just generic titles yeah even like you
know even going out a layer from that is
that even all the paranormal shows all
have really really generic titles so
it's like Paranormal encounters like you
know a haunting the haunted haunted
places haunted houses haunted [ __ ] you
know what I mean it's just kind of like
somebody's gonna throw it in the
comments Ghost Hunters ghosts
lurkers ghost Lookers ghosts you know
what I mean the good thing about the
Canadian one is that each episode might
have three or four cases on it because a
lot of the cases they talked about were
just witness testimony and they did they
only saw like one thing
but you know yeah so so they didn't try
to stretch that out right
right and uh which made it more contact
content packed like you know they might
have three little epic cases on a single
episode
that all have a similar theme but it's
not the same case like apparitions you
know what I mean yeah and I got yes on
operation and one of the ones the guy
said man well this is totally off topic
well not really I mean it is a
paranormal show so they had this one the
dude
just the way he was talking about it
um I believed him
he was in Canada somewhere and he was uh
young in his 20s and he moves in with uh
two other broke dick guys you know how
you are in your 20s and you're a guy you
don't have any damn money well uh girls
in their 20s
they move in the stem dilapidated house
or dilapidated as Gordon Ramsay would
say well it's dilapidated they'll
actually say you're both wrong yeah okay
she's like a grammar Nazi
but uh they move into this thing at this
house and he had to take a room that had
a [ __ ] support pole that went right
down next to it and it was leaking I
think he said Lake water and he set up a
cot next to that pole and put a sleeping
bag on it and was I think he said it was
a sleeping bag was sleeping in it and
he'd been they've been working [ __ ] up
shifts and everything you know young
dudes do
and in the middle and he he came in from
work
and got into the cot and was just
getting ready to go to sleep and he
heard
uh he thought he heard the front door
open and closed and somebody walked down
the hallway going real slow like they
were
dragging their feet
and he uh looks up through the sleeping
bag and saw
just a shadowy figure
come into the room and it was just he
said I think he said it looked like the
Grim Reaper it was just it had a big
Hood
and a big cloak
and I think he just said it was an
outline he couldn't make any
any you know there was it was like a
two-dimensional moving
figure coming into the room and it
walked up to the foot near the foot of
his cotton just said and it's he said it
in a totally normal friendly voice said
I just thought I'd come in here and uh
and then it vanished
yeah I just thought I'd come in here and
uh nope
I do not like that and he said that he
said it haunted him for the rest of his
life you're just going to come in here
and do what and what kill me uh rest
what is it hang out and he said he said
what was weird is that the voice that
came out of it was totally normal
but just it didn't look it didn't sound
anything like it like it looked and he
said he was awake he said he didn't fall
asleep said he was awake he said he
couldn't go to sleep the rest of the
night
[ __ ] like that yeah is way creepier to
me than like the real kind of like try
hard this is so scary kind of like
because it's just it has no context to
it no context and it's just kind of like
and it leaves this mystery in your brain
like I said yeah I'm about to come in
here and um
and then it faded away
[Laughter]
I would shave my pants if that happened
like I said that's like a lot scarier to
me than if like a demon came in it was
like I heard that one and I just thought
what it was is somehow he had picked up
on some kind of a residual
there was a and something left over from
the past like Halloran was saying like
burnt toast it's just pictures in a book
something from the past
and there's no context it was just and
it may have not it probably wasn't there
it probably wasn't something you could
photograph it was just some kind of
psychic impression that goes directly
into your Consciousness and you think
you saw it was something it was
something that happened in the past
and for somehow he just picked up on
that little part of it somebody walking
in the middle of the night had weird
images I'm just going to come in here
and um you know
wouldn't it have been funny if it was
like a dude that lived there a long time
ago and it was Halloween and they
dressed up like the Grim Reaper and he
just came into his roommate's room and
said hey I'm just gonna come in here and
like borrow your Scythe or something
like that like and then like for some
reason that like imprinted itself on the
[ __ ] it was just something as like
innocuous as that I had a feeling it was
going to be something along the lines I
was going to come in here and warm up a
little bit something like that
maybe if somebody had frozen to death or
something I'm in Canada I don't know
and it probably didn't look the way he
saw it right he did the dude probably
didn't look that way he just he probably
just was it's just that how his mind
interpreted it as something scary so he
saw it as the Grim Reaper
but the message was I'm just gonna come
in here and um
I need to write a short story about that
that's creepy as [ __ ] because like I
said I love
like just on like stuff that with no
context like that is like way way
creepier to me than stuff that's yeah
very clearly evil yeah another one um
that was a good story a guy was watching
television
and he got real sleepy he was smoking a
cigarette
and he was looking at the smoke of his
cigarette and it started to put him in a
trance he saw the smoke go up out of his
cigarette and form a little ball about
two inches in in diameter just like a
little ball and then the ball slowly
started to
change into a pattern that looked like I
think he said it was blue and white
plaid
and then he snapped out of it
two days later
there's a EMTs were in the hallway
taking somebody out of the room and his
room may have been dead for like two or
three days in there and when he went by
he saw underneath the cloak the [ __ ]
that blue plaid of that guy's shirt
he saw that guy's shirt somehow again he
thought that he thought that somehow he
had either picked up on it psychically
or
or it tried to give him a message try to
show him that he was over there right
and they had died that's why it was a
good series I think it was called
strange encounters maybe paranormal
encounter yeah that sounds like but like
I said there's so many that have similar
titles if we could find it I'm sure it's
probably streaming on somewhere like TV
or Hulu or something like that because a
lot of those are
it was a Canadian series yeah
Danny Rowling says it sucked the mother
in this episode didn't even believe her
own son I mean he could have gotten
raped by the ghost in front of the mom
and she would have just played it down
oh he must have just had some gas well
the thing about it is that and there's
like even less excuse for her in this
episode because she's a Paranormal
Investigator yes I know that they kind
of like couched it as like she's a very
skeptical Paranormal Investigator but
you would think like if this [ __ ] is
happening to your own kid
um you know and she even said like later
on that she felt kind of bad because
she's like oh if this happened to
somebody else like if somebody else had
called her up and reported it and said
hey you know come investigate it then
she would have taken it seriously but
like when it happened to her own kid
like she didn't want to like she just
thought he was being a brat or whatever
like until later on she was just kind of
like oh okay maybe it's a poltergeist
but it took a really long time you know
for her to kind of get On The Clue bus
sort of thing I'm Ray van Pierre said I
once had a nightmare about a vampire
when I woke up there was a bite mark on
my right hand it was way wider than my
own Dental imprint so I didn't bite
myself sleep paralysis I assume now I
guess so I've only had sleep paralysis
one time
in my whole life like and I know some
people have it all the time because I
have a problem many times I have a
friend that has it like really bad and
it's like some of the stuff that she
told me that she saw was like really
really horrible I mean the one time I
had it was I woke up and I saw like a
dude standing in my bedroom door this is
when I lived alone and I um he was
standing in my bedroom door like holding
a baseball bat up but the thing about it
was that when I woke up
it didn't scare me like I saw him
standing there but for some reason like
I immediately knew that it wasn't really
there
I don't know how I knew that I just did
I have sleep paralysis or sleep
paralysis for me is always associated
with out-of-body experiences I had that
damn Out of Body Experience when I was
in the Army and sleeping paralysis was
involved I did a whole show on it
um and I also had
there was been I've had times where
I for some reason woke up in in the
middle of sleeping but was paralyzed and
I was kind of in an otherworldly state
where I could see the room but inside
the room there were other things
like dream material or imagery and stuff
um
one that comes to mind is that uh
I woke up and I was paralyzed I was in
the room and I looked at the wall
and the wall started to kind of like
Bend and morph and I could see faces and
distant faces of people that I knew and
I could hear what they were thinking and
what they were saying and
it didn't surprise me but it was kind of
like looking into a
like a crystal ball it was under the
impression that I was reading the
thoughts of people that I knew that were
far away
but I didn't really learn anything
important and then it just faded away I
relaxed and went back to sleep it was
weird
and then sometimes you have a sleep
paralysis and you'll be paralyzed and
then you go back into a dream
but all of a sudden you're in control of
the dream you can drive it and you know
that you're in a dream
that's weird too have you ever done that
yeah you know you're dreaming yeah I'm
gonna do this in the dream and it's kind
of like a roller coaster ride and you
can see things and fly and but then you
can't hold on to it for long if it goes
away you go you lose Consciousness again
you're totally conscious of being in a
dream it's weird the weird in-between
State yeah I've had that happen so many
times
um Camp guy said sometimes I jerk right
as I'm going to sleep it's just a quick
one-time thing that happens to me a lot
I'm just jerk before to go to sleep
no usually what it is I'll usually like
I'll be like half asleep and then I'll
dream that I'm it's usually that I'm
walking down the back steps at my
grandmother's house and I fall and then
I'm like you know what I mean like I
wake up like I fell down the steps like
I don't know why I almost always like
kind of half dream that I'm falling down
steps or that I'm walking somewhere and
I trip like a [ __ ] klutz yeah as you
get older your your brain uh kind of
becomes a little more efficient and
better organized so these weird
phenomena don't happen as much that's
why some people take like mind-altering
drugs which kind of brings
brings us some of those abilities back
like DMT and as LSD can kind of do stuff
like that
and that's why Indians did that you know
taking Spirit walks and stuff taking
masculine and peyote
which can kind of alter the
consciousness
yeah I gotta like open up those Pathways
yeah free yourself from efficiency
Camp guy says falling and flying dreams
are common yeah
um another very common and I didn't even
realize this because I used to have
dreams like this all the time
but I didn't realize it was really
common so later is uh dreams or your
teeth are falling out yeah and it was
usually kind of like um in school
well I mean I had them like for
I haven't had one in probably like
several years but I used to have them
all the time but it was all like the
context was always different like it was
always kind of like a dream just a
random ass dream like hey I'm walking
through the McDonald's drive-through or
whatever [ __ ] dream I was having and
then all of a sudden
um all my teeth would start falling out
and it was really Vivid like that part
like you could feel I could feel the
teeth falling like out over my lips
coming out like like rows of corn yeah
like so much so that when I woke up I
was like like oh my God my teeth are
gone it's like oh okay it was just a
dream like it hit the ground and [ __ ]
scattered yeah like all that kind of
stuff I used to have that woo I used to
have that all the time yeah and I didn't
even realize that other people had that
until later I thought it was just like
some weird [ __ ] thing that happened
to me I'd have these weird dreams where
some of them recently you know like in
the past four or five years
you're in high school
and you're confused as [ __ ] about what
your next class is and you're saying
you're and you're trying to look at your
damn schedule and you can't make heads
or tails out of it and you know what I
mean the period bells are reading a lot
of people what the [ __ ] what what's my
next class yeah I have that one I don't
think I ever had any like that that is a
really common one that people have I
don't think I ever had any about school
specifically I have had some where it's
like I woke up and I'm like oh my God
I'm late for work or I'm late for a
meeting or something like that but not
really all that often I think the teeth
falling out one because Ben says
psychiatrists are very interested in
dreams about teeth I think what they've
come to I don't know if this is true or
not but they've usually come to the
conclusion that if you have a lot of
dreams that your teeth are falling out
it's because you feel like you don't
have any um Power like you're powerless
like in your own life or something like
that because I guess teeth maybe yeah
well I guess because teeth kind of
signify like back in you know the
caveman days like if you your teeth fell
out of people in your feet you'd kind of
be like uh you'd be in big trouble so
you kind of had to like rely on
everybody else so I don't know if that's
sure or not but that's what a lot that's
kind of what they're what about the one
you're in the shopping mall and you
can't find your way out every time I've
had that a few times yeah every time you
go up the escalator you end up on the
bottom floor every time you go into one
[ __ ] one one store you end up in
another one everything is kind of like a
Mobius strip you see the [ __ ] door
out but as you go to it you never make
it to the door out you end up walking in
yeah that one frustrated me too
and you're in a crowded shopping mall
and you can't get out you know it was
[ __ ] crazy we went when me and my
sister went to Disney like a few weeks
back uh I specifically told her I said
well I want to go on the Peter Pan ride
because when I was a kid I remember
having a dream about the Peter Pan ride
specifically like and going over the um
the alligator like the crocodile or
whatever that's coming out of the floor
and I said but the weird thing about it
is that on in the actual ride if you
don't know you're like in a ship and
it's kind of like it's attached to the
ceiling so it kind of like goes like
that
um but in my dream I was for some reason
just standing on a tiny little piece of
fur
I I don't know why it was just it looked
like one of those like big Band-Aids
except like with fur in the middle and I
was standing on it it was like a magic
carpet and it was like flying me around
like over the crocodile's mouth and
everything like that so I don't know why
I still remember that campuses he has
that exact same dream a lot I guess he's
talking about you got to give me context
because I never see these
these comments on time he must be
talking about the
the the shopping center dream can't get
I can't get out of the shopping center
escalator you end up back on the back
bottom floor again and stuff yeah
frustrating as [ __ ] yeah you're like
that's it I'm gonna go out I walked into
one of the shopping centers had a
grocery store in it it had a conveyor
belt taking the groceries out to the dam
to the parking lot where they were
loading them into the car and I said I'm
getting on the conveyor belt and as the
conveyor Bart started to go inside it it
[ __ ] ended up not out in the parking
lot but in the bookstore
it's like an adult and bookstore how'd I
end up here I had been like well I'm
just gonna stay in the middle yeah I'm
trying to get a couple of crowds of
people everywhere it's like something
about a THX 1138 you know that's funny
yeah Camp guy said my teeth went bad in
real life I didn't have to do anything
to help it uh my dentist and I are
pretty tight she pulls out her adding
machine every time she sees me walk in
the door yeah I mean I'm kind of Lucky
in the fact that I haven't really had
too much trouble with my teeth had a
couple cavities I had like one in the
way way back that kind of cracked and
fell out but other than that not so much
so
yeah American Military 100 said I'm so
happy you brought that up Jenny I still
have bad bad dreams where my teeth fall
out I always thought I was the only one
just like yourself it's a different
context every time yeah and it's just
like it'll be a dream about something it
does nothing to do with teeth it's
nothing to do with anything it'll just
be like some random ass stupid dream and
then all of a sudden like my teeth will
start falling out my head and I'm just
like where the [ __ ] is this coming from
and it's always always super super Vivid
Mark's got Mark's got a good one too
since he has a reoccurring dream and
walking outside and witness a passion
passengers oh I've had that one too yeah
that one a lot I've had that one like at
least three or four times yeah I've
watched it and sometimes it falls apart
and breaks apart and people falling out
through the sky yeah I've had that one
too I had another one I I had that I had
that dream one time where the plane was
kind of coming towards me a little bit
breaking apart in the air and I'm
running from oh [ __ ] it's gonna hit me
and then as it gets closer and closer
and closer it's not getting any bigger
and I catch it it's only the size of a
model and I'm looking at it and there's
little people in it
I was thinking myself this is worth a
[ __ ] mint
I mean look at this thing with all these
little people and [ __ ] I'ma hit the
jackpot but I woke up it's really weird
though because honestly one of my worst
fears uh I mean of several that I have
but one of my worst fears is being like
in a plane and like the plane you know
plunging out of the sky that's why I
don't really like to fly in airplanes
I'm always like really anxious about it
so whenever I dream and I have had the
same dream several times thankfully uh
I'm always on the ground and I always
see it like over there like crash into a
field and like blow up or something like
I always have dreams like that I don't
think I've ever dreamed that I was on a
plane that crashed which is good because
I'd probably like [ __ ] have a heart
attack and die like in my sleep because
it would be [ __ ] terrifying I had
some weird ass dreams when I was a
little kid
yeah I did too one of them was I [ __ ]
went out in the backyard
and and found a [ __ ] basically it was
a folk or try play but it was it was
like my size which would have made it
you know 20 30 foot dot maybe 20 20 no
not even that it'd probably be about 10
feet across the wingspan and I got in
that little thing it was like a large
model because I had this dream and I was
about I don't know six or seven
and I got in that [ __ ] tri-plane and
I was at the time I was living in
California
uh in Long Beach I got in that trip line
[ __ ] took off and the backyard was
flying all over [ __ ]
[ __ ] Carson yeah I was above Carson
looking at the houses and [ __ ] and I was
a little kid flying an airplane I was
[ __ ] jacked
another one I had
I had this bad habit
getting a hose and [ __ ] digging and
making
you know do it in the backyard [ __ ]
dig out rivers and [ __ ] oh I used to
do that too fill them up [ __ ] with water
then my dad would come out and be like
you're making the whole [ __ ] yeah my
mom didn't care make a moat and
everything yeah if I had a dream I had a
dream I was doing that and I had this
[ __ ] elaborate thing it looked like
[ __ ] Splash Mountain or something out
of the [ __ ]
it was you know small you know [ __ ]
it was only about eight eight inches
wide but it was all over the [ __ ]
yard
and I had that [ __ ] filled with water I
even had [ __ ] fake volcanoes going
I was yeah I was like it was like
something out of [ __ ] Willy Wonka and
I'm standing next to this little [ __ ]
fake river that I made and [ __ ]
coming down the [ __ ] River I couldn't
believe it it was a [ __ ] pirate ship
oh I love this job yeah the pirate ship
about that big I love it I said look at
that thing and I look on the [ __ ]
look on the deck of the pirate ship and
Yosemite Sam is that they're [ __ ]
yelling at me shooting at me other
players yeah yeah damn it it gets better
it gets better I'll reach down and grab
that sound [ __ ] like that and bite and
bite his [ __ ] hat right through his
head and he was filled with [ __ ] that
Ultra hot [ __ ] Cherry feeling Thai
feeling from the McDonald's [ __ ]
cherry pie I'm burning my mouth and [ __ ]
yeah I bit his ass like I was Godzilla
shooting at me with those [ __ ] huge
yeah yeah
the ship went by and everything you know
hahaha that's so awesome that's one of
the best dreams ever yeah
and then that made me laugh so hard the
first time yeah I had several dreams
where I was digging in the backyard one
time I was digging in the backyard and
[ __ ] a hole went through and I was
like whoa and it was a hollow space
I was like what the [ __ ] and I stuck my
head to it and looked around and I was
looking at a cave there was a whole
it was Hollow was there three stacks on
there no but there was there were
stalactites and stalagmites cool
and the surface of the Earth was only
six inches deep
everywhere
all over the whole planet
you could dig six inches and [ __ ] be
in something that you were just a roof
you were just like an eggshell you could
break through and then and then you go
under there and then there's the mole
people yeah I never I didn't jump in
there I was scared but it was light
it wasn't even dark in there so it is
like the mold you can see it yeah
surprised something I saw in a movie I
got a 50s sci-fi yeah like small people
yeah
I've seen that multiple times but so
yeah same kind of thing it was like
there's people that lived down there but
they were all like all super pale
obviously because they didn't see the
Sun but it was kind of like fake yeah
and all they ate was mushrooms okay look
we gotta get the case man we're having a
good time talking about dreams
everybody's talking about I know it's
like well you know it's paranormal
adjacent it's paranormal adjacent yeah
all right so uh yeah we'll just kind of
let you throw in like whenever if you
want to come up with this because you
watched this episode too yeah
there were some I'll get into it you'll
get into it I'll get into it all right
so like there's some things that rank
true and some things that didn't but
okay yeah I'm not really sure how I feel
about this one to be honest with you
um so yeah so this one is actually set
in Syracuse New York so as I said we got
a Paranormal Investigator Stacy Jones I
think she's been on a couple of other
episodes also like talking about other
cases but this is her own case so she's
married to a dude named Lloyd who
doesn't really like figure into it all
that much it's her second husband I
guess and she has a 15 year old son
named Jamie who is also on the show
now so Stacy I guess uh she was like a
former police officer I was reading an
uh an interview with her where she said
she actually wanted to go to college for
parapsychology but by the time that she
got to college age the only college that
still did parapsychology was Duke and
she's like well she either couldn't get
in there she couldn't afford it so she's
like well I guess I'll go be a cop
instead because okay uh so she went and
you know became cop
now she actually felt like her being a
cop made her a really good Paranormal
Investigator because she was always like
relying on skepticism and evidence and
stuff like that which you know that's
that's probably Fair
so she does like a bunch of um you know
she's like lectures and stuff like that
on the subject
um and she was also at the time she said
that this happened she was also a
full-time student so there was like a
lot going on uh and again she's friends
with John Zappos who you know if you
don't know was the nephew of the Warrens
so he's like a demonologist kind of guy
he's on a lot of these episodes as well
so she was the one that founded Central
New York Ghost Hunters I don't know if
it's still around or not but apparently
it you know swelled to uh at least 75
members or so they say and that was in
2012. so her husband Lloyd not really
that much of a Believer but you know
kind of supportive anyway
uh Jamie who is the son he said he kind
of grew up with it so you know the
Paranormal seemed normal to him because
it was just always something his mom was
into
so uh so yeah so like I said the Son and
the mom were both on the show like for
real John zappis was on there and I
think the priest that did the eventual
exorcism was on there also but this was
the only like real people that were on
there Stacy said that she mostly only
focuses on human Spirits whereas John
saphis John Zappos is more like the
demon guy you know what I mean like
he'll go into John's epis the demon the
demon guy that's what it is a good
series
he's the demon guy yeah he's the one
that's like the you know the non-human
entities that's why she only deals with
human entities she's not dealing with
any of that demonic [ __ ] okay John
zephis the demon guy
yeah Ben said Duke was the only college
that offered parapsychology at least
back in the day yeah I kind of feel like
for a while there were there was Duke
and then I think there was well there I
think there was three other ones for a
little while but then like for a while I
think Duke was the only one I don't even
know if Duke still does parapsychology
anymore
um oh well I think what happened with
her was that well she's like well they
do parapsychology but you have to get
like a p it's a PhD program and she was
just kind of like ain't no one got time
for that it could be you know because it
takes a long time to get a PhD
so you know what I mean but I don't even
know if they do that anymore uh so okay
so Stacy and her team which on this show
is like two it's like a guy and another
woman and the other woman uh the little
short woman with the glasses she that
actress has been on a bunch of other
episodes too like I think she played
like psychics and [ __ ] like that on
other episodes because they all have the
same a lot of these have this you know
the same stable of actors or whatever so
this team is going to investigate a
local Cemetery where there have been a
bunch of reports of ghostly activity
so um her and her family I guess her and
her family they were supposed to go on a
picnic that day anyway because it was
like a Saturday so she ends up going on
the picnic with the Son and the husband
uh you know kind of in a field or
whatever a park or whatever like across
from the cemetery and then the
paranormal team is there as well now
Jamie decides the 15 year old kid he's
gonna help out on the investigation too
now I guess this was something he didn't
really do that much before but he was
just kind of like yeah I'm just gonna
hang out I'll do the investigation with
you hanging out in a cemetery I mean
that sounds kind of fun it's like kind
of scary or whatever he's like well I
don't really want to hang out alone at
home because I guess the dad Lloyd I
guess like he worked at night so he
wasn't there like they always work at
night on this [ __ ] show all the men
do which is really weird to me it
happens a lot
so now Stacy said Well normally she's
like we investigated other cemeteries
and they're usually like pretty benign
places so she didn't really think there
was any danger in taking Jamie along
with her like she didn't think anything
bad was gonna happen famous last words
so the funny thing about this was that
even at the introduction or even when
they're talking about the cemetery I
can't remember what cemetery it was or
even if it was like if they said what
the real place was called
but
um they basically the narrator Anthony
call he says uh this Cemetery houses
bodies of soldiers killed in like every
war since 18 whatever and I was like so
like pretty much every other cemetery in
the United States then or will I mean
like pretty much any other like large
Cemetery would have soldiers from
pretty much everything all the war yeah
yeah that's like so that I mean the way
that they said it was like it was super
unusual yeah that's common but then
we'll see the thing about it too and
I've noticed this too like usually in
his introductions like he'll be like you
know uh you know Cleveland Ohio or
whatever the [ __ ] the the places this
stuff is taking place he'll always
they'll always try to make that location
seem like creepier than any other
location by basically saying you know
the city of whatever it is is
underpinned by uh by the dead and stuff
like that I'm like well everywhere is
though I mean I know it sounds scarier
when you say it like that but if you
think about it for five seconds I'm just
kind of like and I I've kind of got the
same Vibe like with this Cemetery they
were saying it houses like all its body
soldiers killed in violent ways I'm like
well yeah that's generally how soldiers
and Wars get killed violently
um in Ohio a place where lots of people
die
I like like everywhere else like
everywhere
the most haunted place in the earth
would be Rome it's been there for what
[ __ ] 3 000 years
the city of Rome was behind we're like
ancient Egypt yeah some [ __ ] like that
yeah something whereas humans have lived
in great numbers for a really long time
yeah density every square inch ahead of
you [ __ ] die on it in the past
three thousand years I mean it was at
this point like unless a place is super
super remote I kind of feel like most
places if it's a city if it's been a
city for any length of time yeah yeah
you're walking all over dead people
there's dead people everywhere and this
accidents have happened in places people
just dying in their sleep everywhere
yeah that's why okay fight you are you
set yeah that's what I mean so it's just
like kind of like even if nobody died in
your house specifically it's like people
have probably died on that area before
land where the house was there yeah so
it's like you know I don't worry too
much about it I don't worry too much
about it because like I said If ghosts
were real and if everybody came back as
a ghost then there would be you wouldn't
be able to move for the ghosts you would
they would just be like overlapping
ghosts like everywhere yeah and in a lot
of places at least the United States the
cemetery business is kind of especially
during the 18 and the early 1900s was
pretty [ __ ] um Shady
chances are there's a lot of stuff built
on top of cemeteries you know yeah after
that cemeteries old they just moved the
headstones they just build something on
top of it yeah oh they both yeah and he
was out in the middle of the country
back in the day but now that's [ __ ]
center of town
well yeah and I mean once all those
people's relatives are dead too and
nobody yeah it's like you know that's
sad but yeah most people get forgotten
that's just like the way yeah of that's
the way [ __ ] goes and the caskets of all
[ __ ] collapsed and right they're just
bones and they may not even be bones to
fit if there's [ __ ] if there's ground
water or things have changed it may not
even be bones yeah it might just be like
little pieces of pieces of stuff Zach
says the city of endless murder hog
swallow Alabama I do like I get it
they're trying to like you know they're
trying to set the scene yeah and they're
trying to say like this place is scarier
than any other than most other places
but it's just kind of like I don't know
that's like that's funny to me like the
way they always try to do that like try
to make everything seem like different
than another place yeah places are all
about the same
yeah I mean essentially yeah and this
like I said this is Syracuse New York so
yeah that's kind of like in the upper
like New England D type of area so you
know it's it's gonna be there's gonna be
all kind of like [ __ ] dead bodies and
haunted [ __ ] up there but you know it's
that's just the same as everywhere else
it's I'm not that worried about it
so uh so yes they go to the cemetery
whatever it is
now Stacy said that she had gotten a lot
of emails from people saying that they'd
seen like uh you know apparitions of
like weird [ __ ] in this Cemetery in
particular mostly what she said was like
Shadows moving around in there
um so she said though that she's like
well I'm pretty skeptical of these
reports initially it's like you know a
lot of people will go to cemeteries and
hang out like just because they want to
be scared so sometimes they'll just like
see what they want to see or they'll
make something out of nothing so that's
kind of like the attitude that she was
going into it like that you know what I
mean so uh the team has all the usual
like high-tech equipment like you're you
know [ __ ] with the cameras and the
EVP [ __ ] and all that kind of stuff but
one of the guys like the guy brings
dowsing rods yeah now Stacy uh doesn't
really see much use for these she's like
basically she's like well maybe it can
find anything that's like ionized quote
unquote like it's like maybe you can
find groundwater maybe you can find
metal or something like that but she's
like I don't think it can find ghosts or
it can do like any kind of paranormal
[ __ ] so she just doesn't really see the
point of it
um so she's just like whatever she just
thinks it's really silly so the guy on
the team though like shows Jamie how to
use them which basically just entails
hey just hold him like that and wait for
them to vibrate and like lead you
someplace so there's that
so once they get into the cemetery uh
Stacy and Jamie go off and investigate
like the back this other these two
quadrants over here and then like the
other two people who's I don't even know
if they said what their names are but
they went over to the other half
cemetery and farted right over there
So Jamie basically she's like he's like
well what the [ __ ] am I supposed to do
with these dowsing rocks like what are
they supposed to do and then his mom was
just kind of like hey why don't you like
tell it to find a grave that has the
name Smith on it or something like that
and she was like joking you know what I
mean so he's like okay find me a grave
that says Smith on it
um and then like nothing happens at
first but then Jamie said that the rod
started like vibrating all weird and
started like kind of clicking together
and like kind of pointing him toward
this I don't know it's almost like a
clump of Shrubbery or something like
that like by this big tree or whatever
so he got kind of goes over there and
he's like Mom these are like acting
really weird so they go over there and
they pull all the bushes aside and lo
and behold they find a flat grave under
there that has the name yada yada Smith
on it and Jamie's like well that's
pretty [ __ ] freaky although Stacy
points out rightly so that Smith is a
very very common last name and it's
probably just a coincidence she's like
you know this is a very big cemetery and
there's probably lots of graves that
have the name Smith on them and honestly
like I said it would have been a lot
more impressive if they'd have come up
with like some [ __ ] crazy ass like
really really rare last name and then it
found that you know what I mean but even
then it's like that kid could have been
at that Cemetery before and known that
grade was there and then like pulled you
know what I mean there's all kind of
like stuff that could really have I
always wanted about dowsing rods because
it used to be back when I was a kid
it was rumored that oil companies were
hiring famous Dowsers
to go out with those things and they I
think they did some
it is a TV special when I was a kid I
think it must have been back in the 70s
oh I know what you're talking about I
saw that that guy was going out and he
was famous for finding oil
and that his his success rate was
evidently greater than the geologists
that were saying I'd probably dig here
and little oil companies were hired him
to go out I think it was out in Texas
to put
Wells
it's not like it was but now I think I
don't think anybody can just put a well
and have your own oil company they got
it monopolized now it used to be you
could just have oil well in your
backyard
I remember Mississippi people had the
oil wells back there a little bitty oil
well I know something look like a
grasshopper yeah the size of a car out
in somebody's backyard sitting there
pumping oil
they'd sell it just pump it into a
barrel they stopped all that
people making three four hundred dollars
a month popping up pumping oil anyway uh
somebody mentioned that Pliny the
Younger in ancient Rome reported to
seeing a ghost yeah his story is kind of
odd too it was uh he sees the ghost in
his rattling chains and [ __ ]
and he looked at it and he ignored it
because he knew things like that didn't
exist but then it kept rattling chains
and [ __ ] with him he had to hey
all right what I can't remember what it
did it asked him to do something or
something and then um but that's that's
just that's something else when you
ignore a ghost because you know things
like that don't exist that's hardcore
yeah like ah
things like that don't exist you're a
fragment of an underdone potato yeah he
went back to he went back to reading his
book
he said that he was staying in an old
house that was reported to be haunted
this is back in you know 2000 years ago
in Rome
although I remember come walking away
from reading that or hearing about that
I think somebody was reporting what he I
was reading a book where it was reported
exactly what he said in his book
but Pliny the Younger had said and it
read like uh
kind of like a morality Tale
it didn't read like something that
actually happened
yeah I mean they could make up stories
back then yeah and if chances are reply
to the younger probably didn't didn't
write it
because there was a lot of forger there
was a lot of forged books back in the
day
if you wanted to make good money back in
the day you could Forge a book
supposedly written by Socrates they did
it all the time
they would [ __ ] yeah they had no
shame they had no shame they'd [ __ ]
before they'd Forge [ __ ] Socrates
they'd Forge Plato they'd floor they'd
Forge uh [ __ ] Galen they would Forge
anything
they forged the Bible the the Bible not
really the Bible
the books that ended up being put into
the New Testament and and
some of those are forgeries some some of
that [ __ ] is fake Paul
it's still in there though I got
canonized I mean because that's the
thing like any [ __ ] can like
write anything as long as it kind of
sounds legit a lot of people are like
okay
it's not like there was any way to check
no but they would sell fake Paul in the
marketplace and fake little books and
Thomas the Gospel of Thomas probably
Affair is a fake you can still get it
but the Christian authors wrote
Christian fanfic constant before the
Bible was canonized it took them forever
to go through all that [ __ ] to end up
with a cannon to make the New Testament
and they still
some of that shit's a forgery and it's
in there
Christians get mad when I say that but
[ __ ] Scholars that read the original
Greek and this and that's right
that is not Paul talking that's fake
Paul that's true I forgot which one it
is I guess it's very very easy to learn
very easy fake [ __ ] back then yeah very
easy and not all the New Testaments are
the same you know each church has their
own Canon
Greek Orthodox and the Egyptian [ __ ]
Egyptian Coptic New Testaments different
and it's it's mostly the same but it's
got different selection of books in it
there's some African versions that have
stuff in the Christian African stuff
Ben says it was a long period in Jewish
history where it was illegal to declare
yourself a prophet so people would find
prophecies by Noah Moses lives Etc and
circulate them yeah yeah you just
laughed someone else's name on it like I
said it's the same kind of [ __ ] they do
nowadays where it's like I'm gonna write
a novel but I don't think it's gonna
sell so I'm gonna say it's like based on
a true story or something like that like
it's harder to get away with nowadays
but
you know it happened like people are no
different God of God of Abraham books
is a religious uh it would be a good way
to put it
all those books that were centered
around the god of Abraham
were kind of a
kind of like the MCU they were a genre
of literature
and uh good dudes wrote them
okay yeah it's like fanfics yeah
and it's all written in a style
okay and an accepted style of that era
and that style is a religious style it
other books written at the same time did
not have that style
so when you're picking those books up
they were from day one they were written
to be religious manuscripts religious
Dot and it was a just just my out of my
shoe I thought Blake Pookie made that
noise she was squeaking on on now here's
the thing
you could definitely say The Book of
Mormons like that
and I'm gonna say everything that I've
read about Islam is like that and you
can say well that's fan fiction
they're all equally like that
so it's difficult it's difficult to draw
a line between
they're genres of literature
and they're articles of faith you know
what I mean
they're all about the same just because
you think it's ridiculous you think it's
ridiculous but they don't think it's
ridiculous and that's just a universal
[ __ ] thing and it's right there in
that Pauline material they're talking
about hey I think it's already we only
believe in our supper and our savior
don't listen to to them with their
supper and their savior
more than one Jesus and more than one
Christianity the different verses of
Christianity fighting each other it's
just like hey man they're [ __ ] Batman
is [ __ ] up that [ __ ] spent you know
what I mean that was written by some
other guys that's not real Batman that's
not real Superman that's not real Star
Wars that's Turkish knockoff that's
Turkish
oh no no no no that [ __ ] that Ryan
Johnson Star Wars that's not [ __ ]
Star Wars that's what they're talking
about in that yeah yeah so you guys are
still having that fight it's that same
these are nerd fiction fiction these are
yeah these are nerds yeah this is what
these are nerds Bible nerds nerds yeah
yeah the whole time it's like nothing
with Nerds they're fighting over the MCU
they're fighting over DC and Marvel
they're fighting over that that's not
the real Superman that's a reboot you
know that's what they're talking about
you raped my childhood yeah it's like
that it's been going on for thousands of
years nothing's new yeah that's what I
mean that's why it's just nowadays I
just kind of roll my assets yeah
it's like okay I mean I'm not saying I
don't get like nerd out about stuff
because I do but I'm just saying I'm not
gonna get like [ __ ] outraged about it
because that's very silly to me yeah
don't take any of that seriously Ben
says up until the late 19th century book
publishing was a total laissez-faire
Enterprise that is true yeah you had
almost no way of knowing if a book in
your hand was really written by or
published by who it was reported yet
it's just like today yeah it's just like
today they're worried about fake news
and [ __ ] oh this is disinformation
and this what [ __ ] history books have
you been reading news was always fake
always
it was called yellow journalism I was I
came up in high school where they warned
you yeah the news is fake it's called
yellow journalism they're all [ __ ]
claiming different things you can pay a
newspaper to write anything
and they have their own allies that they
protect and their own enemies that they
run that they run up against it's all
propaganda propaganda lies
and you can lie by Omission there's a
bunch of stylistic ways to massage
anything to be anything
but nowadays they said well if you don't
believe our [ __ ] then that's [ __ ]
disinformation man [ __ ] you that's on
you to figure out who's lying and who's
telling the truth you know because
they're gonna punish you for wrong think
you know what I mean oh you're thinking
the wrong thing you got to go to a
concentration camp that's eventually
what it gets down to that's what it was
in other places of the world
you gotta be careful man [ __ ] them do
you believe what you want to believe
based upon what you find to dig up but I
don't trust Authority they lie they're
rich
if you're rich you got [ __ ] to protect
you're gonna lie that's what you're
gonna do you're gonna hire armies of
lawyers and writers to lie for you so
you can continue to make money
Denny Rowling said the demon in this
episode was weak as [ __ ] and barely had
any control over the kid unlike other
episodes yeah yeah I will say it was a
little at the end of this with a little
anti-climactic we'll say that we'll say
that
um even not even any levitation is at
least the possessed had some levitation
you know what I mean yeah weakest
on-screen possession this was it didn't
really make the kid do anything other
than act like a regular bratty teenager
pretty much you know what I mean yeah
okay so anyway where was I okay so
another drink
so uh so yeah there the whole thing with
the dowsing rods and uh she's like yeah
well there's probably lots of graves in
here that have Smith like the last name
on there so don't get too excited about
it she's like maybe there was just water
or metal or something like that like
underneath the grave so you know it's
probably nothing now at this point like
the other two members of the team like I
said whose names I don't remember if
they even set them are over on the other
side and they're just like [ __ ]
around like drinking coffee out of a
thermos or nothing so I guess like
nothing's going on over there so they
call it Stacy on the radio being like
hey what's going on she's like yes not
[ __ ] all going on over here but then
Jamie like I get there's kind of like a
period where and I'm not really sure
like why this happened but I guess like
where his mom wandered off to like look
at some [ __ ] or whatever or he wandered
off to look at some [ __ ] and then like
he couldn't find her for a minute so
he's like keeps calling her so he's like
looking around going mom where'd you go
blah blah blah and um then he kind of
looks over and starts seeing
like shadow people running around like
behind like
like a bunch of them you know what I
mean like they're like going from the
gravestones to like the trees and [ __ ]
like that like running around behind the
grapes
so I guess Stacy like the mom because
the kid is like you know [ __ ] bricks
I was like what the [ __ ] is that and
like the mom starts freaking out too
because she's like well that's not good
whatever that is so she starts like
snapping pictures of it like over there
and then she's like you know what um
probably we should get the [ __ ] out of
here because I don't like the look of
that what okay yeah
[Laughter]
yeah she's like basically she said in
the quote that she said from the show
was they were quote unquote black forms
that Dart between trees and tombstones
so that's what they were seeing now
Stacy calls the other ones on the radio
and says yeah we need to get the [ __ ]
out of Dodge um and they immediately
like pack up all their [ __ ] they're like
okay well we know that Stacy doesn't
usually like overreact to [ __ ]
so the fact that she's kind of like
freaking out on the radio saying we have
to leave it's like obviously there's
something bad
so she has determined that these shadow
people are not human Spirits they're
either demons or simply dark negative
energies in the form of people I guess
but that's kind of what they're seeing
she's like those aren't human ghosts so
this is not this is this is above my pay
grade so I'm gonna get out of here
basically
um now for a time when they're leaving
the cemetery I don't know how big the
cemetery is but they can't really find
their way out so they're kind of like
wandering around and they kind of like
hear footsteps behind them for a little
while but like don't see anybody and
then Stacy said she felt like she was
being surrounded like they were being
surrounded like something was like
watching them or some [ __ ] like that and
it was like really freaky so finally
they hear the two of the other two like
of the team like calling them from the
parking lot
and at that point it's implied that one
of the shadow people like then enters
Jaime's body because he goes like all
blurry like whoa you know what I mean
like that so I mean I guess like it goes
because you know and you know me we're
like sitting there in the bed watching
it and I'm just like did it just go to
his booty hole or in a booty hole it had
to go in somewhere like in one of the
orifices right yeah it could have gone
up his nose maybe right or it could have
just been like
I don't know how shadow people work
these women are always thinking about
going up and sticking stuff in your
videos
yes you can't you just can't separate
women and their fantasies of [ __ ]
going up in the middle
I couldn't believe Ben was confirmed by
other females that yeah that they yeah
they they fantasize about that he says
you got to watch these women man
[Laughter]
we're the worst yeah they're watching
too much that gay porn
that's what it is yeah
Victor says holy crap I didn't even know
you all streamed on Mondays I'm never
off on Mondays LOL yeah we've been
streaming on Mondays for a long time
like we used to do movie reviews but
then a few months back because everybody
asked us to go back to do like a
haunting episode so we started doing
that so now like for the last few months
we've been doing like a haunting episode
every Monday so and then we do movies on
Sunday and Tuesday so welcome on the
yeah these are super fun actually and we
drink on this [ __ ] too yeah we don't
drink as much yeah we don't drink as
much like we don't get as [ __ ] up as
well we don't get as [ __ ] up as Tom
was on Friday if you if you watch that
man I was [ __ ] [ __ ] up the next day
like on Saturday like we slept kind of
late and he didn't remember anything and
he comes in my office like at you know
11 or 12 the next day and he's like last
night was a cluster [ __ ] wasn't it yeah
yeah
I'm like I think so I think it was yeah
I couldn't even remember riding back
from the biker bar but that's not good I
went back chicken Mitch I went
downstairs to check to make sure the
motorcycle wasn't in the garage it says
it is well I knew you because I wasn't
drunk and I and you left before me and I
was in my car yeah so I was like well if
you had wrecked then I would have found
you because we would have gone back I
don't think I was drunk when I left
though
no I think I got drunk later on the show
well yeah and it had a retrograde
amnesia amnesia yeah yeah had red yeah
and that happens sometimes because
um no everything is put away properly
and you know I don't remember having any
problem going home I don't remember
being drunk at the bar
other than you being on the pole and
stuff like that oh you you girls are
eating that [ __ ] up do you remember
being on the phone yeah I went up on a
pole and started
I was looking good too my old ladies
turn around looking like yeah they're
all in their 60s and [ __ ] you know well
not all of them but yeah yeah I'm gonna
get up in your booty hole yeah yeah this
[ __ ] 60 year old women [ __ ]
showing hold on I'll be right back there
they come back with a [ __ ] [ __ ]
dildo is [ __ ] you never can't tell these
are [ __ ] biker women man you got to
watch that [ __ ] right that's right I
don't know bargain women and [ __ ]
Farm people Farm hands and [ __ ] ranchers
and [ __ ]
that's right we got all kind of stuff
going on our brains all the time y'all
don't know the half of it women are
pervert it man we're the worst perverted
yeah we just don't like well you know we
just don't impress it you don't express
it no we just we just keep that just
keep ourselves
we're I mean but honestly well I know
like I said
women said their imaginations tend to be
like a lot more [ __ ] up imagination
because sometimes like you know because
I read a lot of like uh horror and stuff
and say like sometimes I'll read some
like extreme Horror by men and I'm like
yeah it's [ __ ] up but nah but then
I'll read some [ __ ] that some women
wrote I'm like holy [ __ ] that's really
[ __ ] up it's like a lot more imagine
Jen's written porn too of of all the
stuff that she she's written in the past
the porn's all gone though now right
yeah I didn't really write that much of
it it's just you know yeah and most of
it was like kind of funny because it was
it funny like it's like Chuck tangle
type [ __ ] yeah yeah
some of it wasn't funny but like some I
had more fun when it was like funny yeah
you know what I mean
um yeah okay so where was I oh where was
I okay oh we're talking about um the
shadow people going into the kids booty
hole okay so that's that's how we got
distracted that that was the point okay
so they all leave the cemetery and they
go back home seemingly everything's fine
because nobody knows about the shadow
person like you know soaking into
Jamie's body a lot of bad said some
funny [ __ ] read what bad says about the
Landover Baptist
Landover Baptist online Ministry has an
expert in homosexual propaganda and
media manipulation as part of his
research he's watched over 8 000 gay
porn movies
um I don't know if you guys know but
Landover Baptist it's like a um it's a
joke site it's kind of like the onion
but of like it's supposed to be like a
real it's set up like it's a real
religious group but they're actually
like trolls they're actually like
you know what I mean it's actually like
a joke so it's like the onion but it's
they're super super funny it's super
funny
but yeah so if anybody I haven't been
there in a while but yeah I remember it
being really funny he's watched it right
that was a gay porn movies
Mark says speaking of hauntings the
Ammon house case has been on the patreon
poll a couple times I know and it never
wins
um I hope you guys do a show on it
because it's pretty damn interesting
case with credible Witnesses I always
really like that case and I'm always
surprised
maybe I'll have to like I'll have to
manipulate the polls and like I'll put
it in a poll with like a bunch of lame
topics and then maybe it'll win I never
know what's gonna win though it's always
something different like because
sometimes I'm like oh well everybody
wanted paranormal stuff so I put
paranormal stuff and then it doesn't win
or sometimes it's true crime or
sometimes it's history I never know like
what's gonna win from week to week like
I try to put a good combo like if you're
not on our patreon
he should go in there oh you have to you
only have to give like a dollar a month
and you can vote in the polls like and
you can vote on the topic and you can
vote on whatever we do the movie
retrospective on and I usually put like
five choices and I usually try to do a
good thing like I'll put one or two like
True Crime cases I'll put like a history
case or just like a weird history kind
of thing like a paranormal thing ghost
stories like [ __ ] like that so I try to
have like a good like variety of stuff
but I'm always like interested to see
what wins this week actually Wednesday
night uh the topic that won was Lisa
McPherson the Scientology
uh murder ish
you know uh not so much murder it's more
like neglect yeah neglect that resulted
in a negligent homicide yeah and I'm
actually like really excited that that
one because I've been wanting to you
know somebody mentioned it and I was
like yeah maybe we should do a show
we've done a couple shows about
scientology like in general but I don't
think we've done a show like talking
about her case specifically and I did
work with some people that knew her and
like were her roommates and [ __ ] like
that and were around and like testified
at the trial and all that kind of stuff
so um so I thought that would be like a
really good job
that'd be a really good show eventually
we will do the Ammon house case
seriously because I wrote about it in
unseen hand and it's like a really
interesting case honestly uh so
hopefully it'll win one of these days if
it doesn't like maybe we'll just do a
maybe we'll do a haunting Mondays about
it just we'll cheat you know what I mean
we can do that it's our Channel
um but yeah
so they all go back home everything
seems to be fine now the next morning
Stacy looks at the pictures that she
took at the cemetery like while all the
shadow people were like running about
but she doesn't see anything unusual
so her husband Lloyd like comes home
from his night shift and he's like hey
how was the big like ghost hunt or
whatever and she's like well you know we
kind of saw some [ __ ] and I didn't
really get any documentation though and
he's like well maybe that's because
there wasn't anything there yuck yuck
yuck you know what I mean I'm like yeah
thanks you're very very helpful so
anyway Jamie wakes up now this part was
kind of funny this this part thank you
Victor thank you do a JonBenet Ramsey
revisit for Christmas tis the season
yeah I actually did a show I did a
JonBenet Ramsey uh run down on my crime
immemorial Channel like and then I did
it and then I was like well [ __ ] I
should have waited and done that on
Christmas time but oh well did we do did
we do a Die Hard Review
um that's a Christmas I'm sure we did
but I'll I'll have to look if we didn't
do because when does because December is
coming and I usually like to do
Christmas horror and Christmas movies
like right around for the whole month
we'll do it for the whole month but I
want to do ones that we haven't done
before because I mean I've done a lot of
like Christmas horror movies we don't
Christmas evil I've done a Christmas
Horror Story yeah we do Christmas
Chronicles we did Christmas Chronicles
we did Christmas Chronicles too right
yeah we did I know you're making another
one I heard well I yeah that wouldn't
surprise me because it was like pretty
popular
I didn't mind the second one the second
one wasn't great I mean the first one
the first one's fantastic I really
really like the first one we watched it
every year yeah uh the second one I
think we watched the second one again
last year but it's not as good I didn't
like the belts nickel I like the idea of
putting Bell's Nickel in it
um you know watch our Christmas
creatures show from like several years
ago like if you want to know uh the all
of the info about Bell snuggle but I
like that they put that character in
there but I just didn't love the way it
was integrated into the story you know
what I mean that's I kind of think that
was my main issue with it
um I do like that actor though because
I've seen him in some other things I
just don't know if that was the right
direction to go in for that character
but anyway
it's a bunch of [ __ ] they could put in a
third one
I mean Christmas mythology is just so
and like I said if they're willing to go
belts nickel it's like why don't they go
like what's up I mean they're Indigo you
could do a win to go couldn't you no
well I mean I was gonna say you could do
Krampus but I mean but they've already
done I mean there is a definitive like
really really good holiday comedy horror
movie called Krampus that I kind of feel
like is the definitive and there's like
a million Krampus movies now but I kind
of feel like maybe there's so much weird
Christmas mythology that you could do
why don't they do one about the
Christmas witch yeah from Italy what's
her [ __ ] name
uh
uh I think it starts with a B I can't
remember what it is right now but yeah
there's like the Christmas witch that
flies on the brain but like throws
presents out and [ __ ] like that come on
do that that's that'd be [ __ ] badass
all right so um anyway
where was I okay so Jamie wakes up the
next morning
and uh this is kind of where the
credibility starts uh crumbling away a
little bit for me because Jamie wakes up
and sees that there's like a
five-pointed star not like a pentagram
because it's not like because you're not
a pentagram it's like you know you draw
it like that it's like crossed over type
thing yeah this one was kind of just
like the outline does that make any
sense yeah it's like the outside it
looks like a cookie like a star-shaped
cookie is what it looks like
um so it's on his thigh yeah I was
looking at that I was called [ __ ] on
it I'm like no
so it's like it was a brand if you ask
me yeah it was like carved and it was
like what we suspected was that this
[ __ ] he's a teenager he's
starting to go like [ __ ] he was
trying to be edgy he's gone I'll Ed you
Lord and so he's like I'm gonna go get a
brand or a tattoo or something like that
or a scarification or something and then
he's like well [ __ ] how can I um you
know it what if my mom sees this and I
have to come up with some excuse oh a
demon did it yeah that's I I immediately
understood
on the [ __ ] demon which I was like
all right I like I I respect your game
it was either scar it was either
scarification or a brand I mean that's
what it looked like in the show I don't
know what it looked like the star that
he did
that was some [ __ ] that was some
2000s [ __ ] okay it was yeah that would
have been really cool with it in Hot
Topic in the 2000s yeah you know what I
mean [ __ ] I don't know maybe he took
one of his mom's cookie cutter writers
album and [ __ ] you know what I mean [ __ ]
like that when he when he maybe he took
one of his mom's like star-shaped cookie
cutters and like heated it up and then
that's kind of what it looked like yeah
it looked like it starts with like
whatever Christmas cookies yeah he was
cool as [ __ ] he was dating some girl
with a [ __ ] tongue ring and Jake owes
with a [ __ ] short belly shirt I mean
we're just special back in those days
you guys know what I'm talking about
yeah that's what I suspect I don't think
the demon man I don't think the demon
put the star-shaped yeah on his leg Yeah
I think maybe he did that and then like
was trying to come up with some excuse I
don't know like I don't know the guy I'm
just saying that was the first thing
that we thought of
um but yeah so he's like he says like
Mom look at this oh my God like I woke
up and it was there and Stacy uh you
know she was just kind of like no she's
like what did you do to yourself I
didn't do it it just appeared there and
I'm just like a likely story uh but
Jamie at this point said he felt really
betrayed because Stacy didn't believe
him and like I said Stacy is a
Paranormal Investigator so
you would think that you could come up
with like whatever kind of crazy [ __ ]
and she'd just be like oh my God it's
ghost but she totally didn't believe him
so over the next several weeks or
whatever uh Jamie said he started
feeling kind of like numb to everybody
doesn't give a [ __ ] about it anymore he
starts like acting up at school
apparently he like says and does weird
[ __ ] but then a few minutes later like
it doesn't remember it like he gets sent
to like the you know the example that
they give is like he gets sent to the
principal's office at school because he
was sitting in the classroom like and
they said he was mumbling incessantly
like
and I guess they told him to like knock
it off and he didn't
so they sent him to like the um the
principal's office but he didn't like
he insisted that he didn't remember
doing that so there's kind of a thing
where he just keeps like spacing out and
then like he'll space out and then he'll
say something sideways like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] or something like like you
know he didn't say that because it's you
know a family show but that kind of
thing
and then like everyone will get offended
like what did you just say young man and
he was like what I didn't say anything
like he'll just totally act like nothing
happened so he ends up getting three
detentions for all this you know teenage
misbehavior that he's doing
um and he said like well everything was
normal previously so I don't really
understand why everything was like all
this [ __ ] was happening to him and
everything was like turning to crap
because he was just spacing out and he
really realized what he was doing or so
he claimed
uh so yeah so over the next few days or
whatever he says he felt like he was in
a fog he was like you know super
depressed and angry and he didn't really
know where it was coming from and he's
like he wanted to talk to his mom but
she always seemed like too busy to talk
to him so one evening he's in his room
and he's listening to music like the
music that they had him listening to on
the show was actually like pretty good I
thought
you know what I mean just for I mean for
the time period I'm just saying I don't
know who it was but I think it was just
somebody local that they it was just
like some random but yeah it wasn't bad
it wasn't like cheesy or nothing like
that I was like Ah that's all right
um you know if this was like an opening
band for somebody else I wouldn't be bad
about it uh so so he's in his room like
listen to music and kind of like fussing
around with a skateboard or whatever and
a tape dispenser in his room
essentially like picked itself up off
the desk and flew like across the room
and left like a dent in his wall like
across the you know across from where
his desk was
he said that he couldn't believe that it
happened he was just kind of like wait
did that just happen which is the same
thing that we said like when our [ __ ]
started flying around in here
um you know like the the remote control
yeah so he said well he thought that it
almost seemed fake because he couldn't
believe that it had just happened
because it just flew across the room and
hit the wall like that and left a big
dent in it you know yeah some of the
stuff that they report I kind of call
[ __ ] on it but we're gonna say yeah
um well
I've been in that situation usually the
first time you've seen anything like
that happen it's [ __ ] light it's
[ __ ] life-changing it's like an
earth-shattering and then you get all
into the effect of the phenomena itself
what moved how far did it move why did
it move that
they're not asking these questions in
this now in their defense the mom is a
Paranormal Investigator and she
immediately recognizes it as Poltergeist
phenomenon and knows what causes poultry
Poltergeist phenomena to repressed
emotions that explode from explode out
in the form of rspk which is recurrent
spontaneous psychokinesis which that's
what it is
that's what that's what it is
I've seen it my family's seen it Jenny's
seen it
uh it's rare but it does happen
um and I can't explain it yet but there
are certain things that Stuart hammeroff
talks about with Quantum Consciousness
it may it may explain it I think it does
explain it uh
but uh the thing is though is that
usually when you see this [ __ ] you try
to get down to the bottom of it you want
to see what else it can do that's what
you know that what's possible you want
to know what's possible what can it move
and they don't seem to be doing that
which
makes me suspect because you see that
phenomenon you want to see it again
you want to know what it's what what the
limits of it are
and then there's no indication of that
this story
maybe they left it out I don't know
yeah I mean that's what I mean you don't
really know like exactly what happened
because it's just like a reenactment
yeah in reality you become obsessed with
it
you know or very preoccupied with it
you're like
what is this and then when you figure
you know what could it do you know what
did it do what did that mean you know
you start reading into it
one of the funniest things that I didn't
notice this when we watched it last
night but I noticed it when I was doing
the re-watch earlier today like to take
notes about it yeah
um in the kids room did you notice that
there was a Bobby Mackey's poster on the
bedroom wall like it's like country
music or something or other and it said
Bobby mackie's on there I'm like ah that
was like a nice little Easter egg that
they stuck in there that made me laugh I
didn't shout out to another episode yeah
I didn't notice it like when we were
watching it last night but I saw it
today like because I was looking at his
room because I was looking I was like oh
look at all the posters I was trying to
like remember like you know uh recognize
them in the bands and I was like hey
there's a puppy Mackie poster that's
pretty funny but yeah so I thought that
was cool like shout out to another
episode so um so at this point he's like
thinking maybe the house is haunted and
he goes down to tell his mom about it
but she just got the letter from his
school about the detentions and she is
pissed off like why didn't you tell me
about any of this kind of crap uh so
Jamie goes into like [ __ ] demony mode
and starts like talking back to her
caller by our first name like what do
you think that is Stacy blah blah it's
like how do you think you're gonna fix
it all that kind of [ __ ] now Stacy is
kind of concerned um at his like [ __ ]
Behavior but she figures well he's a
teenager and you know how they do um
he's just going through a phase so she
kind of just like blows him off and gets
back to she was you know kind of getting
ready to do a lecture so she's like busy
you know what I mean
so a few hours later I guess Stacy goes
up to say goodnight to him like knocking
on his door but he won't come to the
bedroom door now apparently like a few
hours after that Jamie or at least like
um the the POV camera sneaks into his
parents bedroom later yeah like sneaks
into the parents bedroom later like to
watch them while they're sleeping so
while they're both sleeping and it's
implied that they that uh the POV camera
like steals something out of the mom's
jewelry box you don't know that it's the
jewelry box until later on it just like
looks like the box that's sitting on top
of the dresser
so Halloween is coming up and Stacy has
a bunch of lectures because like I said
she's a paranormal lecturer so of course
it's Halloween everybody wants to hear
that [ __ ] now one evening she comes down
like she's going to one of her lectures
and she's like where the [ __ ] are my
diamond earrings they were in my jewelry
box and now they're gone uh so we are
led to assume that's what was stolen out
of the box
now at this point like Jamie says you
know he's like I can't talk to my mom
like my stepdad's hopeless I can't talk
to him about [ __ ] um and also I don't
have any friends so I don't really have
anybody to talk to
um so this particular night I guess his
mom goes to do a lecture and his dad
goes to work so he's in the house by
himself and he's like sitting in the at
the kitchen table like doing his
homework or whatever and he starts here
in this weird noise he said this is what
he said and I think this is what he said
he said it sounded like a quote-unquote
gross frictiony I think he said
frictiony wet noise
later he described it as like a loud lip
smacking sort of noise that's what he
said it sounded like he said it was
originally coming from the laundry room
but then kind of it was kind of a creepy
noise to me it kind of sounded like and
you know maybe this wasn't what the real
noise sound but on the show it sounded
kind of like if so if it was like a
really really big yucky cockroach like
and its legs were kind of like
like against the wall like it sounded
kind of like that to me but he said it
sounded like loud lip smacking is what
he said it sounded like so he said
originally it's coming from the laundry
room but then like as he goes in the
laundry room then he said it slowly kind
of travels back into the kitchen where
he was to start with and then it goes
into the computer room and he said it
was like interactive so like everywhere
he'd move it sounded like it was like
moving somewhere else like it was trying
to like evade him or something like that
so when his mom gets home Jamie tries to
tell his mom what's been going around
with this weird [ __ ] sound that he
heard while she was gone Stacy is again
like totally blows him off oh you know
it's probably just the neighbor's cat
you know how they always leave that cat
outside I'm like yeah you know the cat
makes a lip smacking noise that sounds
like it's inside your house yeah sure
all the time
um and then Stacy just said well I
thought he was just trying to get
attention
um and Jamie said at this point uh he
just kind of gave up he's like look my
opinion of my mom like totally changed
after that she kept kind of basically
just like blowing him off and like
downplaying his fears and so he just
kind of felt like well [ __ ] you then
so in bed later on Jamie hears that same
weird noise again in his room then he
has like a nightmare which they try to
like make you think could like really
happened but then he's like oh you know
when he wakes up and it's a dream you
know what I mean but in the nightmare
um he sees like his mom hanging from his
ceiling or a ceiling fan or something
like from a you know noose or whatever
and she's all like bloody
um and dead and she's wearing a sign I
had to like back it up a bunch of times
I'm like what the [ __ ] does that sign
say because they only show it for like a
second the sign said you know why that's
what it said because it kept going by
quick and I'm like what the [ __ ] did
that say I thought it said something
more like substantive than that but it
didn't the sign said you know why on it
so his mom's like hang in there so he
said like the dream seemed like really
real and he suspected that um the dream
signified that things were gonna get
like super violent and out of control
like going forward you know what I mean
now Stacy I guess I'm assuming like the
next day while the kids at school she
goes into Jamie's room to put his
laundry away because you know even
though he's clearly old enough to do his
own laundry come on
um but she's kind of like putting his
socks or whatever like in his drawer and
she finds not only like a bad report
card like he the [ __ ] was failing
everything but also finds her diamond
earrings which it looks like he sold
right so he comes home and he's like
what are you doing jigging around in my
drawers blah blah and he just says um
you know she like confronts him about it
like hey you stole my [ __ ] earrings
what the hell and he's just like
whatever I'm out of here like he does
that kind of like teenager thing so he
goes downstairs and Lloyd is down there
the stepdad
and he gets all demoning at that point
like he's well you know deepening
you know the mom is just kind of like
hey you stole from me and he just says
oh I guess I did bad bad Jamie like he
gets like this really like creepy voice
and then his stepdad kind of intervenes
it's like hey don't talk to your mom
like that you little piece of [ __ ] or
whatever and Jamie says shut your mouth
Lloyd which I thought was very very
funny because that was his dad's name
and then he says something else but I
don't remember what it was so Stacy at
this point she's like I'm just like sick
of looking at your stupid face and your
stupid emo hair at this point so please
go back to your room
um but then like he kind of seems to
like snap out of it and he's wondering
like why are you guys yelling at me like
I didn't do anything even though like
literally minutes ago he was just kind
of like you shut up and you shut up he
was just like acting all demoney like I
said he was getting all day money like
you do
um and Stacy said at this point the
thing that scared her the most she said
I didn't even want to be around my son
anymore she's like I didn't even like
him at this point and that like scared
me more than anything because you know
you know how it goes
um and she's like he was just completely
different than he had been just like
three months before this was like
totally not him
so then they interviewed Jamie again and
he says yeah everything went to hell and
there wasn't you know a single thing in
my life for me to be happy about and
then this is the part that I was
mentioning because remember when I said
earlier that there was like this really
really weirdly edited part that I've
never seen any editing like this on
another episode of Haunting
they were interviewing the real Jamie
and he was talking about you know oh I
was like depressed and angry and there
was nothing for me to be happy about
everything was [ __ ] up and stuff like
that but they edited it really really
weird like kind of like choppy or like I
don't know I can't like explain it but
it was like really edited
um they were scratching his voice kinda
it was almost kind of like that and I
said are they
actually like yeah I don't know if they
were trying to do like kind of a like an
edge lordy kind of like mid-2000s I
don't know if they were trying to do
that like they were experimenting except
because I've never seen them do that
before or since and I just thought it
was a strange I don't know if he like
was saying some weird [ __ ] and they just
had to like cut it up so it didn't I
don't know it just if you've seen that
imaginist voice like the Terminator X or
[ __ ] public anime
maybe that's what it was yeah
yeah yeah it was like that was it I mean
it wasn't quite like that but it was
that kind of thing you know what I mean
because I'm watching it being like why
are they editing him like that I've
never seen them do that ever it's just
like it seemed really really weird and I
don't it's I don't know I still don't
understand
but like I said trying to maximize the
creepiness of the if you've seen the
episode you know what I'm talking about
because it was like very very it stood
out a lot because that's like totally
unlike the episode like the editing that
they usually do I just can't figure out
why they did it like that or what they
were trying to get across
so at this point Stacy is downstairs you
know shaking her head at her son's like
terrible report card where everything is
F's
um you know when very suddenly a book
comes flying down the stairs and then it
hit her but it kind of like hit the wall
like near her
so at this way she picks up the book
like what the [ __ ] like I guess she
thought that the that her son like threw
it at her but then she goes up to check
and like no one's up there that could
have thrown it right like he's in his
room and like locked in his room and
there's no way that he could have I
don't know
um so Stacy at this point she's kind of
finally like okay well maybe something
paranormal is going on because I'm just
like chucking books at me
but again like like Tom mentioned um you
know at first he thinks maybe it's a
poltergeist and she's like well I'm kind
of hoping it is a poltergeist because
you know Poltergeist [ __ ] to use all
doesn't usually last that long a time
and it's like so if I only have to put
up with this [ __ ] that he's doing
like for another month or two like I
think I can you know wait it out kind of
thing
the next evening though
um Stacy decides you know normally she
would go to class but she took the class
off so she could stay home and sit and
talk to Jamie but as soon as she starts
talking it was like look I think that
you know maybe you're manifesting a
poltergeist or something like that but
then like big scratches start appearing
all over Jamie's chest and back like
while they're looking because he's like
ow ow and then like he lifts up his
shirt and then like there's all these
cuts and [ __ ] and then like she said I
guess or this is what they showed anyway
that some of them like appeared while
she was looking at him you know it's
also consistent with Poltergeist though
that's what I mean it's just yeah the
thing is though is that
usually in in the other cases that I
read about when you're dealing with
marks appearing on bodies sometimes
before
sometimes sometimes right before your
very eyes
and then you're also um having what
seems to be kind of like
possession what looks like possession
usually the psychokinetic phenomena is
real strong there's a lot of moving
objects there's a lot of [ __ ] being
ripped up and destroyed not they don't
say that in this case
so it's kind of a weird
the proportionality of this case is
weird if you ask me
they don't really talk too much about
objects being moved or teleported or
thrown yeah I mean other than the tape
dispenser in that book that was pretty
much it usually it's real heavy in that
when you have somebody who's exhibiting
what appears to be on the surface to be
to be [ __ ] possession
because
they're they're Poltergeist in its
extreme case and it's an extreme
manifestations can appear to be
possession especially if people
at the scene suggest that it's demonic
possession then it'll kind of become
that I mean it'll give you because
that's the expectation that's the
expectations you'll get it becomes
whatever you want it to be
it just acts out it's a it's a temper
tantrum it's a psychic temper tantrum is
what it is
so yeah so pretty much like the minute
she starts talking to him about
Poltergeist like all these Cuts start
appearing supposedly and he's like
freaking out so she starts freaking out
and then she starts to suspect well
maybe this isn't a poltergeist maybe
it's something worse so she puts him to
bed and like cleans up all the wounds
and everything
and then she calls John's office yeah
let me say something before we go on to
the movie The Exorcist was based upon a
real case
uh but that case involved a little boy
and it was a poltergeist case it yeah
there was there was an exorcism yeah
there was what appeared to be demonic
possession
but even one of the priests that was
involved in it says no no what I know
now it was Poltergeist
you know
one of the one of the witnesses
yeah that was um I don't think they've
ever released the kid's real name but
they usually call it Rolando or okay
Ronald Mannheim or something like that
he goes under like pseudonyms right
Rolando is the one that I usually hear
yeah a long time ago I read a pretty
much it was in the 40s I think yeah I
read a full account of what uh one of
the assistants to the priests had
written down of everything that they saw
and I was like it was it's like
something out of a poltergeist case
you know a lot of moving objects
um
what's called I think it was called
Phantom knowledge is that I forgot I
forgot what the fnf he knew things that
he couldn't have known
uh didn't he did a lot of weird stuff
my name is Poltergeist though
yeah it's because he was a Jewish kid
he was Jewish but his mother remarried
to a Catholic and they started taking
him to Catholic Church he didn't want to
go
so and he was about the right age for
Poltergeist and
he had a damn psychic temper tantrum and
they thought it was the Catholics
thought it was possession so it became
it started to manifest itself as
something like possession like demonic
possession what it looked like that's
not what it was though
so okay so she calls John zappis up and
as soon as she tells him because at
first she's like well I thought it was
Poltergeist and he's like yeah that
sounds like a poltergeist and you know
the kids about the red age and yada yada
but as soon as she talks about the cuts
appearing he's like oh [ __ ] that's
demonic
and then
um she then he asks her about like that
whole like thing at the cemetery and so
he begins to suspect that he probably
picked up this attachment this demon
attachment like at the cemetery it's
like a vacuum cleaner attached movie
it's a demon I hate when that happens
does your vacuum cleaner have a demon
attachment um you know so you can suck
up in demons all right so
yeah and um and then it's just kind of
like this was funny to me because I've
never seen this done either but you know
how usually like um if the Warrens run
an episode or something they'll be like
did you guys use a Ouija board and
they're like yeah we used a Ouija board
you [ __ ] you used a Ouija board
you're never supposed to do that okay so
it was like that but she says to zaphys
yeah when we were at the cemetery like
the other guy like gave Jamie these
dowsing rods and then zaphus was like oh
no
why did the deep I was like look at that
victim blaming [ __ ] you're not
as a d yeah you invited the demon in by
using they always say the dowsing rods
yeah it's you you can't use a single
[ __ ] thing without him fighting
demons in like I said [ __ ]
seriously so yeah so he's like really
offended by the fact that you let him
use dowsing rods you stupid oh [ __ ] yeah
like it wasn't quite that extreme but
the like the look on his face was just
like oh you stupid [ __ ] yeah it
was like that
um so yeah so that obviously attracted
you know the demon attachment
now I'm gonna like I need to invent a
vacuum cleaner that has demons
Electrolux makes it yeah
it does all right so Jamie comes
downstairs and uh zaphus is like uh you
know let's see the the cuts and
everything so he very reluctantly like
shows zaf as the scratches some of which
he said looked like they were brand new
now zephis recommends an exorcism
because of course he does that's kind of
his whole thing but Jamie says
absolutely not he said that all he he
knew about exorcisms was what he saw in
the movies uh specifically in The
Exorcist and he's like yeah I don't
really want any part of that um you know
he's like yeah puking and discard face
and everything it's like yeah no I'm not
about that life
so um but his mom uh you know after
about two minutes like actually
convinces him to go through with it
though and so she drives him to
Connecticut that weekend to I get he was
either zaphus's house or I think they
said it was Larry Elwood's house who was
the priest he was the same priest that
did the [ __ ] in the possessed that we
talked about last week
so they're like friends you know him and
zafes uh and it was the same house and
it was the same actors too which I
thought was a nice touch they used the
same house and the same actors I think
it was the same actors playing zephus
and the same actor playing Larry Elwood
like the priest that was doing that as
far as we know if we line these episodes
up this might be a trilogy yeah it all
might be one long story one long story
yeah probably and they probably just
moved it up and blew your mind didn't it
it might be a Trilogy in there you put
it together yeah gotta see who directed
it on the credits yeah it's like we're
trying to let's just make one big
extended Universe with all of these
they're all happening I mean I guess
technically they're all happening in the
same universe because it's all kind of
like this universe you know what I mean
yeah uh so just like in the possessed
this was also a musical exorcism which I
found delightful this wasn't quite as
musical as the other one basically they
were just like
and then like just for a second and but
you know they they sang a lot more in
the first one so I thought that was
funny now Albert's wife who I don't
think they brought her up on the
possessed even though I'm pretty sure
this is the same priest because I
remember that name
but they said in this one specifically
that elward's wife has quote unquote the
gift of discernment and I said so she
can distinguish one thing from another
yeah yeah we were laughing I'm like I
could do that too yeah
the Christians do that a lot
concerned [ __ ]
they see this and they know what that is
they know that is not that over there
it's a special it's a special it's a
special ability a special thing evident
people can do that it's like a discern
it's so special that they have to like
give it a special name I can discern
even though I'm pretty sure I can do
that too yeah although you know you
don't discern the way that they discern
they're Discerning they know what's good
and what you they know what's right and
wrong that's what it is you don't know
what's right and wrong okay they know
what's that sounds like yeah they know
it's demonic and what's holy and you
don't
um yeah okay I'm just I'm just
apparently the way the way they would no
I know that that sounds about right yeah
you got spiritual antenna yeah they can
figure [ __ ] out yeah yeah
just say which one thing yeah I just
like yeah we went off on that yeah we
were laughing
I was like so she can tell like a
[ __ ] laptop from a brand muffin or
what it's like yeah I can do that too
so
actually they kind of explained it a
little bit I guess I mean I don't really
understand what this works but she says
I guess it means she can go back and
forth like between
I don't know it's like Dimensions or
whatever like she can go inside the
person being possessed like not in a
dirty way I guess well maybe maybe
um
and maybe it can also like go inside the
mind of the demon
so there's that so she can maybe that's
what they mean like she can discern this
I don't know I don't know what it means
it's I don't know
um so so they're doing this [ __ ] she's
uh the wife is there she's like I felt
really nauseated and all this while she
was doing the Discerning now they're
afraid at this point that the demon
might lash out at Stacy the mom just
because you know it's been doing that up
to now so they're like why don't you
just like stay over their classroom
because it doesn't like throw [ __ ] at
you or whatever so the wife they said
tried to discern the Demon's name during
this ritual I was like oh well okay
there you go so maybe she can go inside
the Demon's head and like figure out
what his name is because if he watched
our last show about the possessed I
think I mentioned this before but if you
figure out what the Demon's name is then
you can exercise it because you can say
hey whatever your demon name is uh get
the [ __ ] out of here and then they have
to do it I guess but if you don't know
their name then you don't have any power
over them so I was expecting
just like on the last show that the
demon was going to be Belial again and
no Belial is not well I mean Belial is
the little
um deformed twin in basket case but he's
also a demon
um but this time because I was like is
it Belial it's a it's blyle right no
it's not
um this one seemed like a pretty lame
ass minor demon I think its name was
because I'm kind of scrolling through
and then like the disc that we have this
episode on is kind of like damaged at
this point so I was watching it up it's
because it's old so I was watching it on
my laptop and I kept trying to like skip
through and it kept being like skipping
over damaged area I'm like [ __ ]
I wanted to like you know I wanted to
see what the Demon's name was I thought
it was something like iridium or it not
like iridium like the um you know what I
mean like the um what do you call it the
the chemical compound or whatever but it
was like it looked like irritating but
with
um or ium at then and I was like I never
heard of that demon and that doesn't
even sound like a demon name but okay
but so um I guess this was like some
just irritating David like not anything
that's like super powerful so yeah so
that was the one she's like that's its
name right there like I said she could
discern the demon names that's what she
was Discerning she could discern what
the Demon's name was I got you got you
wouldn't it be funny if like the Demon's
name was just like Steve yeah it'd be
funny
[Laughter]
Aloysius I don't know
nah uh so he's gonna be like [ __ ]
Roger Homer yeah
Ted yeah but yeah so um bill
[Laughter]
all right so uh so yeah
so whatever this Demon's name is
irritating iridium whatever his name is
well it was something like that it
started with irro team so while I was
watching the I told I told them earlier
I was watching the disc in here and it I
guess that part of it was damaged
because my laptop kept saying skipping
over damaged area okay and it was right
when I was trying to like hone in on
like what the Demon's name was my Xbox
placed it cleanly I know we've played
through like but when I was watching my
laptop it just it [ __ ] up just like
the a couple minutes at the end that it
just kind of skipped over but that was
one of the parts that had skipped over
like the Demon's name so uh so yeah so
there's a whole exorcism deal but
unlike in the possessed where we had a
whole like full-on chair levitation
which was pretty neat uh this one didn't
have any levitation no like Paranormal
Activity really
um it's a bit anticlimactic it's just
kind of a bunch of the kid growling and
mugging and thrashing around
and that's about it and then like uh you
know he just kind of falls down it's
like oh the demon left and uh everything
goes back to normal but see every time
they do an exorcism I always wonder
myself if the demon came out what is he
just like floating around a room now
can he go in someone else's booty hole
damn these women
I don't know man I can't I don't
understand this where does it go
why are you asking me I don't [ __ ]
know it's a rhetorical question I don't
know
Megan said I thought it was Bob Bob the
demon yeah
uh yeah so the demon leaves and of
apparently like everything just goes
back to normal and I guess Stacy doesn't
let Jamie go with her on the
investigations anymore because look how
that turned out but yeah so she kind of
she said she kind of felt guilty about
it so was it a demon or was it a
poltergeist
are they saying that's the same thing
because it's not
they never really came down once I guess
they were trying to lead you down the
path because zephus was involved that it
just is a demon yeah yeah well I don't
even well I don't think he said that
okay I think that they thought that it
was a poltergeist at first but then like
when the whole scratching situation
started happening he's like oh well then
it was a demon because I think wasn't it
like in threes and they always say that
that's like demonic right
whether that's true or not I don't know
so well like I don't get these demons
what am I talking about I don't believe
in demons get these religious
demonologists involved and they just
[ __ ] the [ __ ] they just [ __ ] everything
up
so they're asking you to believe this
it's either a psychic temper tantrum
which is some kind of unknown
psychological phenomenon having to do
with say Quantum Consciousness it's
either that
or it's the Fallen Angel entrapped into
the Earth from the Old Testament
or maybe like one of the spirits of the
Evil Dead
like out of the New Testament [ __ ] that
possesses pigs and that you could throw
it out and throw them into pigs and then
throw cast them over the ocean and [ __ ]
sorry Wilbur which is more likely you
know
the Fallen Angel hypothesis or the
psychic temper tantrum hypothesis zaf is
going to say the Fallen Angel [ __ ]
hypothesis [ __ ] is a but then you look
at the description of an Angel
you're talking about a spiritual super
being a god a a one of the sons of God
okay basically literally send the sons
of God
in uh in Genesis okay
these things go into people
for what purpose
that'd be a big step down
to go into a person
you know
you're gonna [ __ ] around with little
people and [ __ ] no see what's being
described in the gym I mean that's one
of the kind of um you know hurdles that
I find really hard to clear like I said
I think the whole concept of demons is
yeah unbelievable to start with but it's
like even if they did exist why the [ __ ]
would they do
something like this yeah why would they
just like mess around with this Penny
Annie [ __ ] scripture
okay
God of Abraham based scripture describes
two different things as demons in the
Old Testament it's a fallen angel that's
being punished
in the New Testament it's the spirits of
the Evil Dead
okay
mostly
early Christianity seems to have been a
[ __ ] exercise exorcism cult
because uh some people running up to
Jesus saying hey you know Master you
know or Jesus Jesus Jesus somebody's out
there [ __ ] casting out demons in your
name man we gotta stop that [ __ ] and
Jesus goes oh hell no hell nobody
talking about he's casting out demons of
mind him no let him do it
so
fighting demons and casting them out
and then as they're described
they're described more like the spirits
of the Evil Dead not Fallen Angels you
know in in the New Testament which falls
the reason why is because that's a very
Greco-Roman idea ghosts is what they're
talking about ghosts ghosts that can
enter people which the Greeks and the
Romans believed in that and Christianity
was a Greco-Roman religion
it's a fake Jewish religion it's not
it's not Jewish it's
it may have had roots in Judaism but
it's become romanized or
greco-romanized so a lot of the
traditions of [ __ ] Greco-Roman
civilization are going to start morphing
into it
they don't they didn't have Traditions
you know the greco-romans didn't have
Traditions about Fallen Angels being
being chained into the Earth for having
sex with the daughters of human men
that's not in their tradition
they expressed it as
Zeus all his sons up on Mount Olympus
they'd sometimes cracking on them human
girls and they'd give birth to demigods
in the Old Testament they call them
Nephilim all right which would be
Goliath Samson
well not Hercules Hercules would be more
like Jesus but uh you know that's what
they're talking about it's just
so Christianity in inherited the
Greco-Roman concept of what a demon is
the spirits of the Evil Dead
not so much a
Fallen Angel but they never really make
a distinction to modern Christian
because they don't know the scriptures
that well
sorry
they're not mythicists they don't
understand mythology works
they don't really understand these
stories and what these stories mean
well I kind of feel like a lot of people
that just grew up with Christianity
don't really like questioned it yeah
they don't read into it they don't
compare it to other religions of its
time and um Christianity Compares very
favorably with Greco-Roman mythology
it's that's it it's the same pretty much
the same
Mega said we need Bruce Campbell because
you talked about it yeah
oh you could definitely say that [ __ ]
the movie The Evil Dead is Christian in
certain ways
yo that's Kristen that falls right in
line well The Exorcist is too so is the
Exorcist yeah
which is like which is very funny yeah
yeah but I mean that's the thing you
could argue like for horror to work
effectively you have to have like some
kind of framework yeah it doesn't have
to necessarily be Christianity but it
has to be like you know good like
everything that everybody can recognize
as well for it to be like perverted yeah
I mean look at this [ __ ] when I was a
kid growing up with Iron Maiden and
Judas Priest and Venom and Slayer and
[ __ ]
Christian parents were [ __ ] piling
them records up and [ __ ] throwing
them out and then [ __ ] trying to tear
your posters off the [ __ ] wall
heavy metals Christian Christian as [ __ ]
none of that would make any sense
without Christianity yeah exactly Venom
makes no sense which is a black metal
band they invented the [ __ ] term
black metal
it's satanic as hell but none of that
would make any sense without a Christian
framework yes Christian
it wouldn't be around that would not
exist without Christianity or the
Christian framework
yeah it's just they're just showing you
different aspect of it and [ __ ] the
dude who [ __ ] wrote that his name is
Conrad lant is is the lead singer and
the inventor of black a [ __ ] Venom
and black metal he didn't believe in any
of that [ __ ] for him he was writing a
horror movie yeah like just like out of
the evil dead he wasn't a Satanist he
didn't believe in any of that
it just it was just the motif that he
wanted yeah all right
and he was having fun with it and just
trolling
but he it it was art form that you know
that's all yeah
if you're gonna he would say they're
accusing me of drinking the blood of
virgins and sacrifice what are you
talking about you know I'm a musician
this is like making a horror movie
that's all this is I'm just making a
horror movie for you guys to listen to
yeah
yeah he didn't believe in any of that
that's probably like the best way to
approach it yes I don't get too offended
about it
Victor says in California you can't
exercise a demon without giving a 30
days notice yeah
you got to notify I mean that seems fair
yeah that seems fair yeah I'm just
saying but yeah so um I did kind of find
an article but I think I went over most
of it about Stacy Jones and I don't know
if she's still like I said I don't know
if she's still around doing paranormal
investigating or anything because the
article was from 2012 and I don't think
her website is up anymore but she was on
a couple of other episodes so there was
that like I said I don't this is an okay
episode
I'm not usually super into like The
Possession ones
because it's like it always ends with
like an exorcism and it's like the last
10 minutes of the show it's just gonna
be like somebody like thrashing around
in a chair yeah you know what I mean so
and occasionally you get like the Cheryl
levitate which that's cool but like
other than that it's usually just like
quickly edited like oh you know what I
mean who's British in there he's saying
yeah it's all the British faults with
all this devil music yeah yeah you guys
did it yeah it was what metal was a
British invention pretty much yeah I
would probably say you know Ozzy
probably in the 70s you could say a
little Deep Purple Maybe
some people would say well Jimi Hendrix
might have been a little bit metal kind
of psychedelic metal you know with
guitar solos but if you're gonna get
that like yeah and then you guys you can
keep going back and back I kind of think
kind of think metal was
in a way a thing of Black Sabbath which
it started kind of and then you read
Black Sabbath lyrics they're not satanic
they're they're Christian basically
basically yeah a lot of the stuff is and
so with Iron Maiden yeah that's [ __ ]
Christian
but it wasn't overtly Christian it's
just that you have to have a Christian
framework a very British which
anglo-americans picked up on that you
know instantly were like yeah yeah
that's it you know you know California
got into it you know with [ __ ] Dave
array and [ __ ] Slayer and [ __ ]
Metallica came he kicked [ __ ] kicked
[ __ ]
kicked iron maiden's ass you know but no
we we picked up on it
um I still kind of give it to the
British the British back in that era you
know Judas Priest you know [ __ ] Rob
Halford was a [ __ ] god basically you
know [ __ ] not all his albums were
good but
commit
his singing was [ __ ] really good very
high I mean say what you will about the
UK and I'm not hating I actually lived
over there for a little while I really
like uh I really like the UK but um they
have given us some amazing [ __ ] music
yeah most of my favorite like 90 of my
favorite music is British I think well
especially that generation you know the
70s and 80s their public education
system included music so they just
created these uh [ __ ] bands you know
these uh guys that they they would make
a hit in England for a couple years and
then England get sick of them and they'd
come over here and make a [ __ ] [ __ ]
ton of money like they like they
basically threw Duran Duran away and
[ __ ] dread rat came over here and
[ __ ] kicked ass they did the same
thing with [ __ ] Billy Idol they threw
his ass away and he came here and became
a superstar mango says Bowie you're all
welcome yeah but yeah thank you very
much 70s [ __ ] 70s kicked ass dude with
the prog rock prog rock movement it goes
back to the 60s with the Beatles really
The Beatles And The Rolling Stones
I'll probably give it to the stones as
being
better than the Beatles they were harder
but the Beatles
yeah and they had a lot of they had a
lot of influence and a lot more
versatile yeah but what's funny is that
you say well they influenced American
Music like American music influence to
the British a lot well yeah it's a back
and Forest yeah I mean like I don't even
think you can go back no yeah because
everything just goes back the stones
copied a lot of [ __ ] southern rock I
mean they were doing fake Southern
Accents and stuff blues and some blues
and it's the same thing with uh with uh
Ozzy Osbourne and early Black Sabbath
they're [ __ ]
it's real they're talking about the
south a lot real Southern Mississippi
delta blues really [ __ ] hard hard
version of [ __ ] Mississippi Blues you
know and uh they're even making
references to it sometimes so
it went both ways it was just a Synergy
yeah well it's just kind of like what we
talk about with like horror movies
specifically like you have the whole
thing about oh like geology movies like
uh were a precursor of slasher movies
which they were but then you have to
think that Italian Jello movies were
also going back to like Alfred Hitchcock
movies like and kind of Noir type of
stuff too so it's just kind of like it's
a constant like back and forth I don't
even really think I don't even think
there's any really such thing as like
kind of a
something that just like comes out of
nowhere somebody's everybody's always
influenced by stuff that came before you
know yeah well it was easy to do because
it was the English-speaking world yeah
where you had England the United States
and Australia were playing off of one
another yeah that had a lot to do with
it yeah because you don't want to
forgive AC DC they kicked [ __ ] ass
well like I said I was gonna bring up
Australia too because like I said one of
my you know one of my favorite bands
slash musicians Nick Cave who was in uh
the birthday party they were like the
birthday party particularly were very
very influenced by so it's by the south
by the Southern Blues and Nick Cave is
still very very influenced by very like
Southern Blues like Old Testament kind
of like Elvis like all that kind of
stuff like he's missing he's really into
that well like I said like in some of
his early songs like [ __ ] that song
Tupelo yeah is essentially about the
birth of Elvis and his dead twin and
like a messiah kind of story yeah so
he's starting to go about the [ __ ] uh
the Elvis mythology of yeah yeah so he
was like fascinated by that he was like
he was all into like Johnny Cash He was
all into that kind of stuff so and there
was like a big thing it wasn't just him
like a lot of people and like people his
age like if that generation like in
Australia were really really into like
American Blues yeah murder album that he
did half of that [ __ ] sounds like it's
happening in a fictional South too yeah
like murder ballads yeah
the southern [ __ ] well and a
lot of them are Blues a lot of those are
blue standards like Stagger Lee
um that's been around like forever if
it's his own version of it but that's
kind of the thing Stagger Lee that
song's been around for [ __ ] decades
and a lot of people have done their own
kind of like versions of it their own
take on it and he did his own take on it
thank you Trey thanks guys the Universal
horror stuff has been so cool yeah we've
been having a good time doing these and
honestly like tomorrow we're gonna do
Dracula's daughter yeah and then later
on this week um if you're a patron
you'll see it on Thursday but if you're
not you'll see it on Friday we're
actually gonna do a Creature from the
Black Lagoon because we watched that
last night yeah hopefully hopefully
y'all went back and watched the uh
Spanish Dracula 1931 which is on TV for
free on to be for free and hopefully you
guys enjoyed that [ __ ] that's the
first time I saw it a couple days ago
and I was just like yeah that's a it's a
better movie in a lot of ways it is
other than Bella Lugosi like I'm gonna
argue that Bella goes he is the better
Dracula but other than that like pretty
much everything is like better and I do
like that guy too but I'm just saying
that I'm gonna say I like them both I'm
gonna give it to Bella Bella but the the
Spanish Dracula was good too just a
different take on it
he was in he was uh an enjoyable vampire
character yeah I had a good time with
that and like I said it was fascinating
like watching the two of them like in
close proximity
uh Ben says have you seen the
proposition yes that was an awesome
awesome movie
awesome movie maybe we should like you
would probably like it actually is that
Robert Redford no no it's um Nick Cave
wrote it actually it's like it's a
western okay and it's like super super
violent it's really good it's good it's
good
um yeah Trey said yep can't wait for
Dracula's daughter and creature and I
own all of those movies yeah we've been
watching now I will say that we watched
son of Dracula and I didn't love it but
we might I mean we might talk about it
anyway I don't know we'll see how we'll
see how it goes but I didn't exactly it
was disappointing I didn't really like
it all that much and then we watched
another one I don't think this was a
universal one
we were watching son of Dracula and you
know how to be if you have to be like
it'll just like play the next movie
whatever it is which is kind of like
related to whatever you're watching so
the next movie that came on I was like
too lazy to turn it off so I was like
whatever [ __ ] it I'm just gonna watch
this and then the next movie was called
Cry Of The Werewolf I'm pretty sure it
was not Universal because it looked
significantly cheaper yeah and I didn't
recognize any of the actors that was
really not great no I don't know what
ear that was from but like the acting
was pretty bad yeah and it was
I don't know I think I dozed off like
during part of it like some of it was
okay but I was just kind of like this is
like really I feel like that that's
something that should have been on MST
honestly
speaking of creatures creatures in the
Black Lagoon the sequel to creature in
the Black Lagoon was called revenge of
the creature was on Mystery Science
Theater and that is actually one of my
favorite episodes that's actually it's
not a bad movie and a couple of the same
people like Nestor paiva like that the
guy that was the boat captain that was
always kind of like making jokes about
everything that guy's in the second one
too but
um watching that movie last night I was
like man I always forget like how good
that [ __ ] suit was holy [ __ ]
for 1954. we'll talk we'll talk about it
yeah but that's it yeah we gotta like
record that one but like I said we're
gonna do Dracula's daughter tomorrow
like on the live stream so that should
be fun
um let's go let's get something to eat
okay I'm making somebody you're hungry
yes okay I got a bunch of that I got a
bunch of Carnitas I need to serve up
okay and then I gotta cook those
pumpkins oh yeah that's right we gotta
sir we gotta start Thanksgiving
preparations this is a whole like
week-long deal because man I'm gonna
stuff my face on Thursday I'm gonna
watch the mystery science theater Turkey
Day Marathon on YouTube hopefully
they're doing it on YouTube again this
year hopefully they haven't moved it to
the gizmoplex but I mean I have a
subscription to that but you know what I
mean
um all right so tomorrow like I said
we're gonna be back talking about
Dracula's daughter thank you for
dropping by talking about a haunting
ghost hunter today and have a good rest
of your evening and we'll see you guys
again tomorrow at 6 p.m Eastern Standard
Time bye